Okay,
he's alive.
All right.
We're live,
Carlos condit and Irwin the core.
Welcome gentlemen.
Welcome.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate you.
Of course.
Thanks for having us.
I'm so happy.
First of all,
for folks who are not aware of the
situation,
what's going on?
Uh,
Carlos Professional MMA fighter,
one of the best in the world,
just fought for the welterweight title.
Extremely close fight against Robbie
lawler.
And you spent a lot of your time this
camp.
How many camps was it?
Were you trained with Irwin to now to
now?
Yep.
And Irwin,
you are a movement specialist and this
is all the rage in mma right now.
It's gets really kind of fascinating as
this sport grows and develops.
We're looking at a sport that's really
only realistically been around since
1993.
That's when it sort of form martial
arts,
of course had been around forever,
but as a sport where people really
started picking it apart and trying to
figure out what's the best way to pursue
this.
It's really only been since about 1993
when the UFC first started and the most
recent trend is guys trying to improve
upon balance movement and their ability
to close distances and attack and be in
a position to constantly be able to do
that in between those techniques.
So instead of concentrating on just
hitting pads or just doing shooting
doubles or doing various drills,
you're concentrating on the movements
that take place in between those
techniques.
Is that a fair way to describe it?
Um,
yeah.
And,
and I think that the movement,
uh,
also helps,
in,
in the techniques themselves,
you know,
we,
we can focus specifically
play on,
on,
you know,
martial arts technique techniques which
are know on a base level movement.
Right,
right.
And how did you guys get hooked up?
Uh,
I reached out to,
to Carlos.
Yeah.
Actually,
it's one of your requirements that you
were commenting on one of those UFC
events and uh,
you,
you talked about the current state of
the welterweight division and at some
point you talked about Carlos and he was
still recovering from his injury and,
and you said that at this point,
uh,
you know,
he was 31 or four years old back then
and uh,
it was a serious injury and that from
then on it could only somewhat gets
slower and that made me react because it
was both true and not true.
True.
From a conventional standpoint,
it's true.
But from a,
a,
a training,
coaching,
a movement practice standpoint,
I knew that there was a possibility to,
to,
uh,
to reverse that,
to improve,
right?
And that this is actually a vacuum and
that made me think Carlos is right
there.
I need to reach out to him.
I can train him and I can show that
there are some different methods that
can bring results.
Even in a seasoned fighters,
uh,
like Carlos,
what is your background turning in the
woods a lot.
The window was a kid moving in the
woods,
climbing trees,
jumping from rock to rock and being
lonely,
being encouraged to do that by my own
dad.
Um,
uh,
in the.
And then later on I did some extreme
trainings I would say in Paris with a
very small group and we would climb
scaffoldings and uh,
we will jump off bridges and we would
balance on top of the class scaffoldings
like popcorn type stuff.
It was,
it was a part of the movement because,
uh,
the founder of par core,
David Bill was almost my neighbor and
practically we're the same age,
but we didn't know each other back then
and I was filling in all the guy and we
would do these,
uh,
these trainings because we were
somewhat,
um,
wanted to go against the normalcy that,
you know,
how heavy the nurse you have normalcy of
wanting to do a to know ourselves,
uh,
through,
through movements and exercises and
challenges that were complete out of,
out of this world.
What do you mean by heavy?
The inertia of normalcy?
What exactly do you mean by that?
Well,
I'd like to save at normal of silent
killer.
A lot of people are just extremely bored
by their day to day routines and kills
them.
It shrinks their comfort zone all the
time.
And um,
uh,
it rubs their,
their,
their creativity,
their vitality,
um,
because we're not meant to live such
predictable lives and,
um,
we're actually,
we're supposed to be extremely
adaptable.
That mental and physical level and we,
we need to train that adaptability by a,
presenting ourselves with the challenges
that are going to maintain that
adaptability.
It's,
it's we need a strategy.
Um,
if a lifestyle is boring,
if we're born in our lives board,
in our lifestyle,
uh,
there's nothing in this world that's
going to really a change that we can
entertain ourselves.
We can consume tons of entertainment,
but what we need truly to get out of
this is a strategy,
a to a perception of oneself that is
different.
And then the strategy that's in line
with that perception of a strongest self
have a more free self.
I don't know,
it's a very philosophical,
but you asked me about it.
Um,
I'm just telling you,
the,
the West,
think about it,
if I had followed a,
you know,
what the box,
the textbooks,
the,
uh,
the conventions,
I would not be in the place I am today,
I would not have done what I've created.
So it's a philosophy as much as it's a
training modality because everything in
life is philosophy,
but you call it philosophy,
outlook,
perspective,
opinion,
values,
whatever you call it,
it's something in your mind is a certain
perception
that makes you see yourself,
see the world a certain way and behave
accordingly.
A bodybuilder,
you may,
you may think that it's purely physical,
but it's not,
it's a philosophy.
The guy who wants to be big as a
perception of himself as being very big
and he's getting to train accordingly.
So it always starts with the perception
and then you behave accordingly.
So everything in that sense,
his philosophy now when you met this
character will apply to all these
movement teachers look like Jesus
because that's a question that's been
coming up over and over again on the
forums when I feel obligated to ask.
Um,
I think there are a lot of the,
the,
the naturalistic persuasion.
So,
uh,
first first impression of Irwin was that
he's very intense.
Uh,
we went and we know there's a wooded
area there in albuquerque and we thought
we're going to go play around,
you know,
walk on some,
walk on some blogs and just kick in
immediately.
It's like,
no,
we're working.
And it was from the first time that we
started,
he was demanding excellence and,
you know,
demanding,
uh,
quite a bit of,
of,
of focus.
And for me,
you know,
I'm kind of like an add type of person
and um,
you know,
I,
that's why I fight.
There's a lot of different things to do.
I can move,
I can play,
I can focus at certain times,
then go fuck around at other times.
And,
and I'm working with Erwin.
It's not only been a beneficial for,
for me physically,
but also,
um,
you know,
as far as my,
my,
uh,
focus and uh,
just my,
my attention.
I'm physically.
Initially it was hard,
man.
I was,
I was maybe seven or eight months off my
knee surgery.
Um,
my body was stiff.
I had a great physical therapist and we
were making progress in,
in that respect.
But,
um,
I wasn't there yet.
I had a lot of imbalances.
I was,
it was still kind of fucked up.
But,
um,
what type of knee surgery you had?
ACL reconstruction.
Did you get cadaver or Patella?
I had an allograft or cadaver.
I like that.
That's my favorite one.
I encourage people to do that.
I know the guys have said that it
doesn't take,
but when guys say it doesn't take,
I always wonder if they were training
too hard,
too quick.
So,
um,
I have a good friend who's a,
a,
a orthopedic surgeon,
and he,
he told me that it's strong initially
because they use somebody,
a Achilles tendon,
which is four times thicker than your
actual 50 percent stronger than a
regular acl.
But as your body's assimilating it,
uh,
it gets weaker.
It apparently your body does this
scaffolding of its own cells around it
as it's assimilating it to your own
tissue and it,
it gets weaker during that point.
Eventually you wait a year,
18 months,
it's going to be stronger than it was
before.
But even that period,
seven,
eight months where you're feeling good,
um,
the inflammation's gone away,
the swelling has gone down.
You're like,
oh,
I feel,
I feel amazing.
I can go fucking train,
I can go spar.
Boom.
You blow it.
Yeah.
And they say it didn't take.
But that's not really true,
right?
I don't,
I don't think it's true.
That wasn't my experience.
I've thankfully,
from what I've talked to doctors,
they,
that's exactly how they said it too,
that you feel really good and you start
training hard.
Then you blow it out at Herman did that,
Dominick Cruz did that.
A bunch of guys have done that and it's,
um,
it's very common.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
Erwin and I started working together
initially.
It's,
man,
I couldn't do hardly any of this stuff
and I'm a high level athlete and it was
frustrating.
So,
um,
I would go and I didn't put a little bit
of information from him,
I'd work a little bit by myself and then
the next time we worked at I had,
I would have made some progress and um,
we'd worked together for,
you know,
once a week,
maybe twice a week for over a year now.
And now how,
how are your camp structured?
Because a lot of people,
they structure the camps are very
regimented.
They have the particular days for
strength and conditioning and it's all
sort of design so that they have enough
time to recover for their skill work and
especially if you're working in that
specific techniques for a specific type
of fighter and you would have to
incorporate all these things and then
this movement training and stuff as
well.
Like how would you figure out when to
put that in?
Did you have to experiment or every camp
really isn't experiment because as I've
grown as an athlete,
I've changed as I've got older,
you know,
I have to take more time off than I did
before.
I have to really,
you know,
pay,
pay attention to my body.
So we do have somewhat of a structure
like that,
but it's also every,
every,
all the scheduling is tentative.
It's like,
okay,
yeah,
I have this scheduled on this day,
but if I'm feeling like shit,
I'm not going to go in there and do
that.
That's,
that's a good way to get hurt.
It's a big fight.
I can't,
I can't get fucked up.
So when you feel like real worn out,
you have to sort of like really be
paying attention to your body?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
and we do active recovery.
My strength conditioning,
the place that I,
that I go,
um,
we do a lot of different things.
They use some biofeedback,
a dove,
a software that is pretty cool.
You stick some fucking sticky pads on
your body and like ekg thing and it can
actually tell you physiologically what
your readiness level is.
And this is being used by a ton of
different.
I'm a professional athlete or
professional teams.
I'm a collegiate teams and professional
teams and Olympians.
So the checking,
like muscle balance,
a lactic acid?
No,
this,
I would,
it would,
it does,
is it measures heart rate variability.
And a central nervous system activity
and the correlation between the two and
whatever their algorithm is that they
come up with to figure out,
you know,
the,
what,
what the correlation means.
They can,
you know,
you got a little dumb screen that shows
you blue,
blue or green,
yellow,
red as far as your trainability I can,
you know,
I can do strength and speed.
Uh,
but my,
my power and strength,
you know,
a level readiness is,
is down.
And then so we,
we use that as a tool.
There's sometimes you just got to go.
Sometimes you've got to go old school
and be like,
you know,
yeah,
this is,
this is fancy but I need to push through
the um,
but it's,
it's a tool to help mitigate
overtraining.
Wow.
That's,
that's really fascinating.
So it seems like experience is probably
the most important thing then.
I think so.
And that's hard though.
When I'm in training camp,
I'm like a race horse man,
I want to fucking run and I really need
somebody to pull back the reigns.
And sometimes I can do that myself.
But sometimes I'm in fucking,
you know,
in shark frenzy mode,
I just go,
go,
go.
And uh,
you know,
and,
I have,
I have to have people around me to be
like,
Hey,
no,
whoa,
ticket to you to kick back.
And your relationship with Irwin,
when you guys first started with how did
you work in the movement training with
all the other stuff that you were doing?
Did you have like a specific day you'd
say,
Hey,
we're going to meet on Tuesday and.
Yeah,
pretty much who's Day aside?
Pretty much,
yeah,
we would go,
uh,
you know,
block out maybe three or four hours
later in the week,
um,
and,
you know,
just hit it and it wasn't always
intense.
That was a cool thing about working with
Irwin.
It wasn't like physically intense.
It was um,
uh,
mentally and neurologically taxing.
So after we did this stuff,
I was absolutely wiped out,
but,
you know,
I got my heart rate up a little bit,
but these weren't hard work as they
weren't taking anatomy physically.
That's interesting.
So what was,
what wiped you out about it?
Um,
I think it was,
we're training the neuromuscular system
and we're training the,
um,
he could probably tell you more about it
than I than I can,
but,
um,
it was,
you know,
really,
really precise,
uh,
movements that just tax tax tax you
neurologically.
And I'm like,
I don't know.
Well,
first of,
for so,
uh,
Carlos is surrounded by a war,
a team of world class people,
a person who was talking about Adrian
have elevate I,
albuquerque is a strength and
conditioning coach.
So he works specifically with him on
this area,
this trending.
And then there is Brendan Gibson and
then there's and Dale and of course
there is Greg Jackson and when
controlling.
So,
um,
so me,
I had to,
uh,
to address areas of training that I
believe the,
where we're lacking a.
If I was to find a word to describe what
we've been training with him,
I would say,
uh,
Carlos would have been training your
brain because the number one reason why
we have a brain from an evolutionary
perspective is for movement.
It's not to discuss fine wine or the
history of art,
which is great.
But originally it's so about a year old
can navigate,
uh,
through complex movement,
through complex environments.
That's the reason why we have a brain,
uh,
so intensity is not necessarily a
raising the heart rate,
you know,
going real hard and burning all over.
Intensity can be in the mindfulness that
you apply to,
uh,
intentionally perform movement very
specifically with a high level of
efficiency that requires a level of
focus that a challenges stimulates and
help the,
the,
the connective,
uh,
functions grope as a matter of fact,
movement itself is a major,
if not the major,
uh,
a secret or,
or,
or reason for,
uh,
helping conductive functions.
It does a whole deal of,
of,
uh,
things,
in the,
in,
you know,
processes in the brain that's going to,
uh,
to,
to help it grow and what you acquire
through movement transfers to any area
of life.
But obviously transfers to better
movement and better movement is not
always just more power,
more uh,
or new techniques.
I told Carlos,
Carlos,
listen,
you've been 20 for 13 years.
Your extremely seasoned,
extremely experienced.
And I bet that a,
you've tried a diverse modalities of
training,
uh,
but that currently you are a,
every camp is pretty much the same in
term of preparation except what's
specific to a game plane for a given
opponent.
So I said you might try to acquire more,
more power.
It's gonna take a lot of energy because
you have already a lot of,
of,
of power for your while you're awake
degree,
uh,
you may try to acquire more endurance,
but that's gonna be putting a lot of
time,
a lot of energy to get that.
You can try to learn more techniques.
But do you have a hurry?
Know already.
So many techniques.
So one of the things that you can do is
to,
to move better.
So any technique that you already know,
we wanted to perform them better.
Okay.
So what is involved in movement
training?
So let's say it's day one,
you get a guy like,
uh,
and he says,
Hey,
uh,
I love this idea that hooked me up.
Well,
uh,
in the case of Carlos,
it had to be something specific to him
as a fighter to what I saw.
I saw,
you know,
what are his fortes is strong points,
but also saw what I believed were
deficiencies.
Uh,
and that may seem presumptuous,
but when I talked to him about it,
what I saw that could be improved,
he said,
well,
that's exactly what I've been told for
years by my coaches.
And what was that a thought that he's,
his stance was too high.
He used these two narrow slowly these
particular,
you know,
uh,
typically Thai boxing square stance,
you know,
with his feet and the l shape,
um,
and um,
and to me that caused a ton of
instabilities,
but also preventing him from being as
fast as I believe he could be in moving
in and out or,
or sideways.
So what adjustments did you make as far
as the stance?
We,
we,
we move the position of his back foot is
orientated,
you know,
at a 90 degree angle.
So we moved it forward more at a 45
degree angle.
But the problem when we did that,
when we have a square stance,
basically your feet are in line,
so if you move you are relatively stable
only because the foot is going that way
that when you move it that way you,
you shrink a bit,
your,
your base of support,
it creates even more instability.
So what you need to do is to have your
feet wider to widen,
you know,
a bit wider on the,
on the,
the front or to the back and then to the
sites like something like,
uh,
with a shoulder width or her hip width.
So that was really a lot of when you,
when I was tweaking something,
it will,
it may create an,
a negative consequence that we had to do
a lot of drilling to,
to improve that stance,
to make it,
to make,
to make it better.
Now the stance that you developed a sort
of classics dance,
you know,
and you're a tall guy,
you would fight and stand up high.
Were there any issues when he started
adjusting the way you place your feet?
Or did you have to relearn things and.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
without a doubt.
Um,
I've been,
I've been training,
you know,
uh,
we tired since I was 15 years old and so
yeah,
I mean these things have been,
uh,
you know,
have been a stratified in my,
in my fricking my muscle memory for,
for years.
Uh,
so yeah,
it took quite a bit of,
and I probably,
you still see me going back to my old
habits.
You're going to,
especially when you're tired or you're
stressed or you're in different
situations,
you are going to revert back to the
thing that you've trained the most.
But when I'm mindful of it for the most
part,
um,
you know,
I,
I definitely think that the improvements
or the,
the,
the adjustments we made were,
uh,
were major improvements.
Um,
we also worked on,
instead of being real,
real heavy on my front leg,
having more
of like an upright stance and upright
stance as far as my torso and not,
uh,
not being so heavy be more 50 slash 50
on my legs and that,
that allowed me to move in and out
faster.
Not only forward but,
but back.
Um,
and that showed big time in the fighting
is Tiago Elvis.
I think that was the reason I was able
to get in,
get inside land with the elbows as
effectively as I did and you know,
and then kind of,
you know,
get,
get the fight rolling.
We're seeing some,
I love watching different sort of
patterns that are developing the fighter
start following.
But one of the things that we're seeing,
there's a lot of people that are
standing and more of a karate stance,
more sideways and wider stance and that
with that,
like sort of Leo Machida style a gunner,
Nelson likes to fight like that.
You can bounce conor Mcgregor,
you bounce in and out easier.
It seems like a,
a lighter foot print sort of stuff.
Damn.
Yeah.
And that's very much what we were aiming
at.
You know,
I executed the way that I do because I'm
a flat footed kind of fucking goofy guy.
And I do,
I do my best,
you know,
I'm,
I'm lucky I got a hard head sometimes
because I'm not Mr technique all the
time.
Um,
but we definitely made an improvement.
I must say that working with Carlos and
uh,
he's uh,
he's extremely focused actually when one
trend there wasn't like no,
it was like a zero fat kind of training,
like completely,
entirely focused from the beginning to
the end.
Always really applied himself during the
training and I know that he drilled a
lot also on these own,
in between every session to make those
adjustments to make them become second
nature because when you,
when you change any aspect of your
technique,
at first it feels unnatural because your
brain is,
you know,
you have something,
a certain patterns that are ingrained in
your,
a neuromuscular memory and they are,
there are a little hard to change.
But Carlos was able to change things
really fast actually.
And I was always impressed about how
fast he would make those progresses.
And again,
those progress is,
were not up that much physical and you
know,
in the sense of strength and
conditioning,
like it would have to work hard to.
It it,
the,
the changes were always told him,
you have the body has it.
What you need is that that map being
newer in your brain somewhere to really
understand,
recognize,
identify and assimilate fully vet
particular pattern.
You've done so many movements,
so many,
so much footwork,
so much,
but the way to do it requires a
different wiring between the mind and
the body,
between the brain and the body.
That's a big part of it,
right?
Is just patterns.
Getting those patterns
ingrained in your system to the point
where they come out automatically,
like you know,
those,
those movements that happen either
inspiring or in competition where all of
a sudden you're executing something and
you had zero thought.
It's just completely.
Your training takes over.
You slip upon and counter and you don't
even.
There's no conscious thought at all and
that has to sort of similarly be
achieved through movement.
Exactly in that,
what's,
that's what stimulated Carla's brain
that much that he had to take a nap
after every training.
Whereas he's used to reread hard
trenton.
But with that training,
which is relatively low intensity and
uh,
the brand is so stimulated that he needs
to recover because it needs to process
while it is,
it's like if the movement,
the mindful movement is the input that
the body that the brain needs to do that
read circuiting a differently,
um,
and to,
uh,
to deconstruct old patterns,
replace them with newer,
more efficient butter.
And that didn't happen while we were
doing it.
You know,
while we were doing a lot of the times I
was struggling with this stuff.
Um,
but I'd go home and I would rest and I'd
go back to my room,
my regular training work a little bit on
and not a whole lot.
But then the next time I would come back
it was almost as if my,
my,
my mind and my body had digested this
stuff and assimilated and it put it into
practical application without like a
unconsciously without me even really
working on it too much.
Um,
you know,
he says that I,
that I would work in in the meantime
between our sessions.
Sometimes I did.
Sometimes I didn't.
Sometimes I had a lot of their stuff,
sometimes you do that,
um,
but it looked like I did,
because I feel like,
and I,
I think this is kind of a consensus that
you make gains,
you know,
during your rest you can lift and lift
and lift and lift,
but if you never rest,
you're never going to make those gains.
The same thing with,
um,
with your technique and um,
you know,
this,
this neurological training,
I think it's,
it works the exact same way
that is the whole movement that's going
on right now is really fascinating
because there's a bunch of different
sort of branches of it.
Um,
and there's like what ido portal is
doing is what you're doing,
but there's also a curse on is doing.
He's the guy who's just trying to get
action coach for Fabry Silverdome and
heartfelt dos Anjos.
And I had him on the podcast and I asked
him like,
what is like one of the most important
things that fighters are lacking and
that you try to improve on?
And he said foot strength.
And I found that to be really
interesting and when I watched what you
guys were doing,
a lot of this barefoot jumping and
leaping and balancing and it requires
some pretty
extreme foot stability is the number one
thing we addressed with car number one
and number one,
I said your feet are not strong and
they're not,
they're not smart enough,
not that that,
that fee to have a brain,
but there is a,
uh,
an extremely strong correlation between
the proprioception in the foot and the
brain and movement.
So most of the time when we move,
we're on our feet and that's the reason
why there are so many sensors,
a nerve terminations in the feet,
thousands and thousands of them.
Why?
Because it's about intelligence
intelligence in the sense of
information.
We talk about proprioception,
extra reception,
which is the particular perception of a,
a given surface and to dixter and he's
asleep or reuse.
It does,
it gives them traction and things like
that.
Uh,
is it,
is it stable or shaky anyways?
So the moment you place your feet,
a boom sends information to the brain,
the brain processes,
and gives order to all the rest of the
body to shift the way to,
to,
uh,
just,
you know,
give some order,
some intention,
it happens without you having to think
about it and it happens extremely fast.
However,
the more you feed are sensitive in that
sense,
the faster information travels up and
back down.
Uh,
and secondly also the stronger of foot
is the more reliable your base of
support is.
So we talk about the strength of the
foot.
We talk about the elasticity of the
muscles in the feet,
uh,
to,
to be sometimes more bouncy,
just simply faster,
uh,
to be also a more endurance to last
longer with elasticy and speed.
Um,
and we did a lot of that through a
balancing drills even like loaded
balancing drills,
but also specific footwork drills and
moving in and out in.
And it was not only a,
the footwork itself,
it's also how the level of alertness
that you have in relation to an open net
and the level of responsiveness that you
have in your movement in relation to
open it because it's not just
reinforcing a particular part of your
body as if you're made of parts it,
it has to work as a whole.
We had to make sure that anything would
improve specifically then would be
brought back to the,
the whole spectrum,
which is movement in a fight and work
and actually improve.
And that's what Carlos did every time
when you would go sparring and then he
would see by himself and then telling me
back,
I've improved.
These have improved that in my coach's
seat too.
So the proof is in the pudding as,
as Carlos would always say it works.
You know,
most people would think that if you're a
fit guy and you're a strong guy and you
know,
I'd say maybe you do squats or something
like that,
you'd have strong.
And
one of the things that shocked me the
most when I started doing yoga is,
that's what would give out.
It's my feet would give out.
I was like,
this is so bizarre.
Like I felt like,
okay,
if I could stand on one foot,
like if you made me stand here on one
foot with my sneakers on,
it's not hard.
They'll stand on one foot.
Okay,
no big deal.
But when you're balancing my feet would
fucking ache,
you know,
like you're doing like bow pose or
something like that and you've got one
leg up here and your arm is stretched
forward.
And you were balancing my feet would be
what was giving out.
And I started thinking about how little
stability,
you know,
most people probably have from training
with shoes on,
lifting weights,
doing,
running with big thick cushy shoes.
Even even elite elite athletes and even
our elite MMA fighters.
And the reason why,
even even when they are training
barefoot in Dojo or in teams.
Um,
but you have to think of what's the
background of a given person.
Most people today in modern populations
grow up indoors.
We have shoes on all the time.
We're walking,
we're walking on flat.
Smooth surfaces are predictable.
There's no challenge to,
to the body.
There's no challenge to the feet.
The feet become numb,
feet become weak structurally.
And uh,
and,
and in term of strength in term of it,
just sorta get a tissue.
Yeah.
So,
um,
if you try and MMA because you are
getting to,
uh,
do uh,
you know,
say,
so striking move on your feet is going
to help,
definitely is going to help your,
your food scraps,
your foot mobility or stability,
but not as much as what you're going to
gain when you have to balance,
uh,
on,
on narrow surfaces and ordinance certain
positions in certain transitions and
kneeling and sitting and get up and get
down.
And especially we've loads on or at a
certain pace,
at a certain speed.
It's different.
And when you make the feet stronger than
your footwork is stronger.
When we talk about movement coaching,
uh,
some people are confused because when
they hear movement in relation to
fighting the footwork and it is work,
but it's also more than that.
Do you remember a few years back,
uh,
it was all the rage you,
you're hearing about a lot of nfl
players were doing ballet.
Do you remember this?
It was a big deal.
Like people will like mocking it,
joking around about it.
And I remember thinking,
man,
that is really interesting.
Very smart.
They must have some sort of benefit in
that if they're doing it.
But if you think about ballet,
the movements are incredibly difficult
and especially if you're a 260 pound
fucking stud athlete covered in muscles.
It's like if you're a thing,
like there was a guy that was in a yoga
class where he leaves his former
football player,
real big guys like six,
four and real thick and heavy and it's
so much harder for him to do these
movements and say like a girl who weighs
100 pounds,
it's like a castle in the sand
inaccurately standard.
It's like an Achilles food.
It's a,
you have a whole mountain that's,
that's built on on the very weak
foundations and ballet of even for nfl
players was actually a very smart move
because when you look at the strength of
the,
the cows,
I had a cousin who was a professional,
a denser,
uh,
her,
her cows or bootstrap was completely
amazing because,
you know,
they do these gracious movement.
People see the grace,
but they make extraordinarily movement
look easy,
but they're not
like floor gymnast too,
I would imagine because they have to
stick your,
your foot has to have the ability to
catch you and then just stay in that
position completely locked.
Then you absorb of foot,
ankle,
knee,
hip stability,
core stability.
I mean,
it,
all,
it starts,
starts in the foot.
I'm balanced.
I mean it's,
everything is integrated of course.
Um,
but it,
it starts to feet.
I saw you doing some of the countdown
shows.
You were doing a lot of jumping over
things,
standing and jumping onto a board and
landing on like,
it looks like a two by four or something
like that.
And locking in place on that.
And it was pretty impressive stuff
because there it is right here,
Jamie,
how you're on the ball,
but like this kind of stuff,
like when you were doing these kinds of
movements,
like,
look,
you'd see it here on this.
How did you,
how do you design these Erewhon and like
what are you looking for different
things specific to Carlos
hundred percent specific to Carlos
because that's the point.
A movement coaching for lack of better
term.
Um,
it's not giving a fighter random
movements that are not fighting
movements,
[inaudible],
Bollywood,
dancing or whatever for a tight.
She couldn't be anything.
It could be any movement.
Movement is such a very.
It's a vast world or universe.
If you're lucky,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
If you'd give something randomly,
you're going to find something that
happens to be useful.
But in,
in the case of Carlos,
I looked at his fights and analyze these
movement.
I had some,
some,
some intuitions about what was there,
what was missing.
And then Isaiah was draining him.
I was constantly adjusting the movement
programs.
What was in every session to what I saw
was working,
what was not working.
What I,
depending on the level of progress that
it wasn't making,
we would do something more difficult or
are the higher level of intensity.
It's,
it's tailored,
it's customized,
not random.
How did you develop this program?
This
is very interesting because I would
imagine that you would get athletes from
a bunch of different sports that would
come to you,
right?
No,
no.
I'm not looking.
I told Carlos,
Carlos,
listen,
I'm focusing harper sent on you,
right?
There is no other athlete that I want to
travel like a gym.
Right?
I mean you have this move.
Nat Is this company of this website?
Yeah.
We have a,
we have thousands of certified trainers
who are using our methods,
thousands of trainers.
I think somewhere around $3,000
to run the wellness world.
The company since 2009.
So this is all your creation.
You've developed this all yourself.
My method,
the method is my creation,
but however I do draw from,
uh,
from the history of physical education,
which I have studied a lot,
especially what comes from Europe and in
my case because I'm originally from
France,
uh,
they used to be a method called a
natural method by a guy called Georgia
bear who himself was not.
He was seen as a pioneer,
but he himself was,
you know,
at some point of that long line of
people before him was a morrows and
pistol lindsay and mercury.
A lot of guys who were working on these
different methods,
but we're talking a,
a 20th century,
19th century,
18th century,
and before and before,
and before,
and back then people didn't have
exercise science.
So what is it that they were training.
They were training the most down to
earth,
practical movements.
They would jump,
they would run,
they would crawl,
they will lift and carry things and
throw and catch things.
Why?
Because these are the movements that
people needed back then that they were
in the military or firefighters.
And when you look at it today,
if there's a situation that say
potentially life threatening,
these are still the movements that you
need to do to save your life or to save
somebody else's life.
They're extremely,
they're natural,
but they're natural also to the point
that they are vital.
So you have this gym,
right?
Um,
what,
what is your normal clientele?
Like?
The normal person that comes to a move
net,
Jim,
it's impossible to a shrink to a
particular category because
do you get like housewives?
You get athletes of all sports?
Yes.
All than young men and women.
Woman comes in,
she's an,
she's a housewife.
Women hate that fucking expression.
A woman comes in who's a non
professional athlete who's just looking
to get back in shape maybe after having
a baby.
Like what?
Do you design a protocol specifically
for her?
Is that what you would do?
Yeah,
it's a lot of classes,
like the movements,
there are some movements
that are a fundamental movements that
anybody can do a.
and then you have more advanced movement
and then you have say a simple jump.
You see Carlos jumping,
like this woman you're talking about
won't be able to do that.
Yes,
you will,
but not at the same level of intensity.
Right?
Oh,
I see.
So you would have her do it alleged
shorter jumps over lower jump on the
spot where he jumped two inches above
ground and lend in the same spot where
you were standing to inches.
I think she could do for.
Have you got a pusher?
Yeah,
exactly.
Well it just needs to keep the training.
Got It.
You know,
never too hard,
too easy.
That was actually also my concern when I
started to try and Carlos because he was
recovering and I was extremely worried
that I wouldn't do anything that would
compromise these recovery in any way
that would actually help him recover
even even faster.
So a method,
you have a method,
only one.
It's scalable and also when it is
progressive and because these movements
are natural,
they belong to all of us.
Like it's like,
um,
what would be the best way to train a
wild tiger?
Like,
can you imagine that you're going to try
to isolate their,
you know,
their hang legs and then try to have
them do another workout for the front
legs and then put them on the,
on the,
uh,
treadmill for cardio.
But I wouldn't make any sense.
That would be hilarious because to be
optimally strong and that Joel and like
a good hunter,
a good Predator,
the well tiger just needs to be and
behave and move like a wall tiger in its
original environment.
But could it be any different?
Tiger on an inverted treadmill and
really pushed that motherfucker some
good music on maybe some motivational
videos,
heater up a drug,
a drug go tiger.
Uh,
well,
you know,
they do that with,
with pit bulls.
Pit Bulls.
When they train them for fighting,
they put them on treadmills.
It's a,
they put them on a,
a treadmill that sort of self propelled
the animals propelling the treadmill and
they'll put something in front of it
that it wants to get to.
So exercise science for four pit bulls.
Yeah.
Well it's a,
it's a real thing.
I mean they sell these.
Yeah,
they wanted,
they have weigh ins,
a serious moment.
Why not?
But my point was everybody needs the
fundamental of,
I believe everybody needs the
of movements before you go through a
very specific science based exercise
for,
for anybody.
Uh,
most people don't need that.
Most people just need to move in the
first place.
There's only men move.
It can't even squat.
Most people are just sedentary.
They're just sitting on offices and
cubicles or what happened,
the cause of most of their,
uh,
physical ailments is that improper
movement behavior,
lack of movement,
or to specialize movement and the lack
of diversity and the good things that,
the antidote for that is movement.
Also movement behaviors,
movement behavior is the cause and the
solution to a lot of physical issues.
Yeah.
When you think about it,
what do we do?
We fucking stand.
We sit,
we lay,
we bend.
That's about it.
That's like four,
four things right throughout our day,
you know,
and that,
that is so,
so narrow of a movement spectrum
compared to what should we do.
We should throw,
we should run,
we should catch,
we could,
should swim.
We should bounce,
we should pull,
we should carry,
we should fight,
we could all,
all this a variety of things that the
human body is supposed to do.
And yet we are like in these constraints
of our,
you know,
we have chairs,
we're sitting here on fucking chairs
for,
there was chairs or fucking,
you know,
a low,
low squat or kneel or,
you know,
um,
there's a,
there's also the,
the,
the neurological benefit of doing those
things because to,
for you to,
um,
to,
to move that way your body has,
or your brain has to do it for you.
Be Fire those stamps.
We're not,
we're not doing that by,
you know,
this,
this boring as shit you or,
or even if we're a fit,
you know,
we're still laying.
We're still,
we were sitting on machines.
I'm doing,
uh,
you know,
elevated,
whatever.
Um,
or something.
Yeah,
it's,
we're still kind of isolated and very
minimal.
Very minimal.
We were not supposed to be like that.
We're supposed to fucking move.
Exactly the,
the,
even the people who who are brave enough
to go against the inertia of normalcy,
um,
and go to the gym and they will exercise
with machines.
I see a huge problem with that type
machines because machines dictates your
movement,
shrinks.
It,
shapes it.
Uh,
you have no choice.
You follow a very simplified pattern
that's imposed by the machine,
right?
This is not who you are.
This is not what she's supposed to be
and move like,
yeah,
because you're supposed to be highly
adaptable in the way you move.
But when you do try to isolate your
muscles,
you're treating yourself like you're
fricking machine.
It's like a factory when you should be
like a wild forest or permaculture
garden or something like that.
It's not what you're designed by
evolution or creation,
whatever to do.
And so bringing it back around to mma,
it,
stepping in the octagon to,
to fighting,
you know,
the nature of our sport has so many
different variables.
I mean,
anything can happen.
We go through,
you know,
we're using various energy systems.
We go from,
you know,
going a Arabic to anaerobic to using an
isometric hold all the way back through,
you know,
so,
so many different things involved
because basically we're able to do
whatever the fuck we want it with,
uh,
you know,
under a very limited amount of rules.
So training this way just just makes
sense.
Um,
because it's,
it's,
it's much more a along the lines of what
we're actually going to do in
competition.
How much of a factor is flexibility play
and how often do you train flexibility.
A lot of,
a lot of,
so flexibility's is,
is huge.
Mobility is huge because the more
mobility and you can explore,
manifest physically have full range of
motion,
but it's also plays a huge role in how
relaxed you are and therefore how much
power you can generate.
And that's actually what was the,
uh,
one of the main point of focus on the
second camp that we did for the fight
for robey.
Um,
so we established a strategy I proposed
as a movement strategy to Carlos and he,
he,
when he talked to Greg Jackson about his
game plane,
they,
they came up with the same thing and
that was to use his ranch to always keep
control of the ranch and therefore
two's,
he's,
he's reached through using these kicks
more and better and um,
we had to address some,
some deficiencies in flexibility because
what we,
what we noticed right away is that when
you was a,
when Carlos was trying to reach a
certain height,
uh,
he had to somewhat go a little beyond
these,
his bag then current level of immune
height.
Yes.
And so when you try to somewhat forced
solidity or mobility,
what creates instability and,
and,
and slows down the movement and then you
also lose this occurs in power and
accuracy.
So we did tons of,
of stretching,
but we did that stretching through
natural movements through all lot of
movement on the ground and,
and um,
yeah,
for those natural patterns.
So I think,
uh,
and you know,
tell me if you agree in MMA as opposed
to traditional martial arts.
I think we skip over a lot of the
intricacies because I know you're a
martial artist,
you're,
you know,
you came up in taekwondo and I feel like
traditional martial arts really
emphasized,
you don't go past this point until
you've mastered this,
this thing.
And it's very a very specialized in mma.
I think we get a guy and he's got a
wrestling background.
Uh,
we'll teach him a little bit of boxing.
Um,
we won't get him necessarily super
crisp,
teach them how to stab a few
submissions,
you know,
get him real strong,
get them in shape and then put them out
there and let him go with intensity.
And a lot of times that'll carry a lot
of guys to the top levels and yet
they've missed some of these smaller,
um,
basic nuts and bolts kind of thing with,
with the movement.
And I think that going back to I'm in
that,
that's all good.
That's all well and good.
I,
you know,
you need,
you need that mix of stuff.
You need the intensity,
you need to be able to get out there and
bring in by down on your mouthpiece and
throw down when it,
when,
when the time comes,
but if you have that,
you can always go back and work on that
other stuff.
That's what I feel like I did quite a
bit with,
uh,
with Irwin is,
you know,
I'm making these tweaks on these,
uh,
these very fundamental things that had
been,
had been skipped over because,
you know,
I'm Kinda,
I'm built.
I got,
I got the fighter thing here and you put
me against whoever I'm to,
I'm going to fucking go,
but now let's refine,
refine,
less refined and,
and maximize and maximize the potential
of what I can do.
Yeah.
It seems like almost having that kind of
go go,
go mentality,
that fighter mentality.
It's obviously a huge benefit when
you're in a fight,
but it almost seems like maybe sometimes
it's against your benefit when you're
training because when you're training
you almost should be looking at it like
a science do.
You almost should be looking at,
instead of like just trying to be the
toughest guy in the room,
you should almost be looking at it like
you're building a castle and you have to
make sure the foundation is good and in
traditional martial arts you have your
white belt techniques and then you know
as you develop in the ranks and you get
new new belts,
you move up and you get a higher ranks.
One of the things you say you get a
higher techniques are more difficult
techniques,
but one of the things you see in mma is
there's guys that have mastered,
like truly mastered one particular
aspect of MMA.
Like Damien Maia is perfect example.
These are legitimate jujitsu master
world champion and because of that his,
his specialty is so strong that he,
when he gets to that spot,
he just got this massive advantage over
almost anybody.
And you see that when he fights like
really good guys.
You know like Gunnar Nelson.
Nelson's a motherfucker,
a motherfucker on the ground yet,
but Damien so goddamn good like neil
magnets and other one neil magnet is so
good.
He's so tough and so,
so good at avoiding submissions is
defense is excellent and Damien just ran
right through them and he runs right
through him because his technique is
Samurai's sword sharp and he has
polished it down and then now he's
learned all the other stuff.
He's learned kickboxing and in the
beginning you didn't have that and
that's why like nate marquardt knocked
him out or all these other guys were,
were able to beat him.
He just didn't have those,
the standup skills.
He didn't have all the other attributes
of,
of MMA,
but that one thing he had honed to like
sort of a mastery level,
whereas some guys never get to that in
anything.
They're really good at everything,
but they never get to a mastery level in
anything.
Yeah.
And I would,
I mean,
I would say that that's probably me.
I'm,
I'm good at a lot of different things.
Um,
maybe not a master at necessarily
anything stand up is pretty high level.
Pretty high level.
Yeah.
You know,
you stand up pretty much anybody,
you know,
I,
I put your standup at a very high level,
but you know,
your submissions are very good too,
man,
but if you spent five years it did
nothing but you Jitsu every day and
started competing in the Monday aisles
and Abu Dhabi and Naga and all that shit
and who knows what the fuck your Jujitsu
it'd be like,
which sounds awesome.
I mean,
yeah,
when I was coming up,
Greg Jackson's gym now is very much a,
you know,
seen as kind of kickboxing strike lots
and lots of striking some,
some,
uh,
some wrestling,
some Jiu Jitsu,
but mainly striking.
Right back in the day when I first
started with Greg and his,
his system and his affiliates,
it was mainly a grappling school.
It was guided Jitsu,
right?
Oh,
Jitsu,
yes sir.
Created.
Yeah.
Um,
well him and some other guys kind of got
together and created this thing.
Does he still call it that or is that.
No,
no,
it's,
that's history,
man.
That's just,
that's old school stuff.
I don't know how the fuck I still
remember that.
Um,
but you know,
a guy like Keith Jardine,
who by the time he got into the UFC was
kickbox and everybody,
when I first met Keith,
Keith was a Jujitsu Guy,
man.
He was competing and in the advanced
level at these,
uh,
grapplers quest tournaments and that
sort of thing.
And then kind of got away from that.
Um,
and you know,
I think my first 12 or 12 or 13 wins or
something,
we're,
we're by submission and now I haven't
had a submission in years.
Yeah.
So I'm just got away from that and I
think the sport kind of evolves and then
it comes full circle,
like it goes one way and then,
and then the other and you see that
with,
with
fighters as well.
Like Paul felder's,
perfect example,
kids is excellent striker and he had
couple really close decision losses to
Barboza and Ross Pearson.
And then he wins his next fight by
submission and attacked with another
submission before he got the rear naked
choke.
You almost got him in a gay teen.
Like you see guys going,
hey,
there's other ways to skin a cat.
Like I gotta I gotta figure out how to
be more predictable or unpredictable
rather.
And I think that that's one of the real
problems with guys who were specialists
strikers,
is that when you fight a guy who's a
specialist striker,
you know that he's not going to be
shooting on you.
So you're more relaxed,
you know,
you can loosen your legs up a little
bit.
You know,
your footwork,
your stance takes a different position
because you're not,
you're not squared off always looking to
sprawl,
hit under hugs.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And you know,
you bring that up in.
That makes me think about my last fight.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a well rounded fighter,
but I said I went in there and had a
kickboxing fight with Robbie.
Um,
well I thought that would actually be to
your benefit because what I said in the
pre fight thing was that you,
you issues you've had in the past with
guys who have been able to hold onto you
and grab you down like Hendrix and that,
that might be a benefit to you in the
Robbie lawler fight because fucking
Robbie,
just,
he's a gladiator.
I mean that dude,
he is so rare in that regard.
He what you see is what you get that
guy,
you know,
he is all bike down the mouthpiece and
move forward and he's got excellent
technique and he's.
She's fucking tough as nails,
but he's a born fighter.
Born funds.
Well,
that's why that fight was so good
between you guys that last round,
man.
Jesus Christ.
When the fucking round was over and you
guys both put your arms on the cage.
You.
That was the.
That was the perfect example of leaving
it all in the octagon.
Yeah.
You guys just emptied out the tank.
You were on fumes and then the Buzzer
rang and you both did the same thing.
When the fuck is that ever happened?
I don't think that's ever happened in a
fight with the fights over and both guys
just walk to the cage.
He didn't hug each other like that
fucking happened.
Later.
I can look at this.
Look at this picture right there.
That's you guys.
That's fucking never happened man.
I've never seen that.
I wasn't conscious of that at that
point.
I think I was on oxygen deprived.
Hypoxic,
yeah,
probably mildly concussed.
Taking shots.
That was a fucking amazing fight.
It was an amazing fight and it was an
amazing round.
That fifth round was just goddamn chaos
mean.
That to me is all of the scariest
aspects of mma as far as damage and you
know,
what you guys are doing to each other
and all the greatest aspects of mma as
far as like display of heart and courage
and willpower and just determination
because you had to be burning.
I mean everything.
What was it like in there?
That fifth round?
I came out and I was,
I was feeling good.
I think I came out and finishing that
fourth round I finished strong.
Almost almost had him finished.
Um,
in that fifth round I knew that he was
going to come out like,
you know,
like a bat out of hell.
So I wanted to finish strong.
And you never know what the,
what the judge.
I didn't know where I was.
I felt like I was maybe up on the
scorecards,
but I'm like,
fuck it,
I need to go out there.
And I started the round really,
really strong I think,
and then he woke up and you know,
came on,
turned on is beast mode,
like he does at the end of a lot of
fights and you know,
had,
had led into some really heavy strikes.
Um,
but it was,
I mean we were just digging.
I don't even remember.
Honestly,
I don't.
I remember at certain points,
I guess the only thing that I could
compare it to was like being in the
ocean and having waves crashing on you
and you're just getting your head above
water just to get enough breath and then
boom,
you're getting another one crashing down
upon you and you are out of breath.
You're fucking struggling for survival
and you know,
and you're just doing your best to
fucking,
you know,
to,
to come up a moment like that in a fight
like that has got to be something that
fuels you in a way that nothing else can
when you're in the gym.
Because you know that those moments can
happen.
Like when you're thinking about slowing
down and a strength and conditioning
program or when you're doing rounds in
the bag and you're thinking about
slowing down that moments,
like thinking about that fight.
I mean,
that has got to be.
Yeah.
That's something tangible you fucking
grab onto when you're hitting those,
those,
those points.
You're hitting your,
your,
your edge and you don't know if you can
go any farther than that sort of thing
that can bring you through.
You know,
there's the debate in mma.
Like what is the most important aspect
of training?
Is it strength and conditioning?
Is it skill training?
How do you,
how do you quantify that when it comes
to a fight camp?
And uh,
one of the things that nickerson was
saying when I talked to him about it,
it's like he believes that one of
fighter comes to him or when a fighter
is preparing for a fight,
they already have all these skills.
They already know how to fight.
They already know how to kickbox here.
And I already know Jujitsu when it comes
down to what a camp is,
he believes that the primary focus
should be on physical preparation.
The primary focus should be on getting
your body to be able to perform at an
extremely high output for a long time or
recover quickly.
And if you can get there that the
benefits of that are greater than the
benefits of just consistently working on
skill training and drilling and all
these other things.
Um,
I think there has to be a balance
because you can be in phenomenal fucking
shape,
ready to go five rounds and then step
out and get knocked the fuck out.
Yeah.
So,
and,
or you could,
you could freeze up.
So I think the,
the,
the mental aspect of it,
the psychological aspect is super,
super important drill,
anything like that.
Do you,
do you have a mental coach or do you
have a visualization drills or anything
along those lines?
I visualize,
I do,
but um,
and I've done this quite a bit,
you know,
I,
a coach I work with ricky lundell talks
about bringing it to the moment,
you know,
it's,
it's about being a game day player.
I love ricky by the way.
He's awesome.
Absolutely.
Great grappler a super smart guy and
just cool as hell.
Yeah.
I just love that guy.
Good all around dude for sure.
But I'm being a game day player,
you know,
you get a lot of these guys in the gym,
they're killers,
world beaters,
but then you know,
the bell rings that are under the bright
lights and they just,
they wilt and the doubts and then come
haunting home.
Yeah.
Well you get and then you get.
These other guys are like,
really?
He's,
he's fighting in the UFC.
You're seeing training.
You're like,
Oh man,
I don't know.
I don't know how well this,
I don't know if I want to watch this.
He's a nice guy.
You're going to get worked.
And then he goes out there and you know,
and,
and does work.
It rises to the occasion and have
accomplished as something that,
you know,
maybe you maybe not even.
He realized that he could do.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an interesting thing to try to
figure out where the balance,
where the focus should be.
And I think it's different for
everybody,
man.
It's different for everybody.
There's no,
there's no one answer.
That's the thing about martial arts,
like I've heard some,
I heard this guy talking about this one,
so it's not an art,
you know,
that it's just people beating each other
up and I'm like,
wow,
that is such an ignorant thing to say
because when you watch someone fight,
you are watching art.
It's just violent.
It's a violent art.
When I watch like your fight with Tiago
Elvis,
you can't tell me that was an art.
That was an artistic performance,
like your interpretation of the
movements in the moment to step in and
blast that elbow.
That's,
that's,
that's a beautiful thing.
I mean it's not beautiful to him or
anybody who cares about him or his
facial structure or.
Yes,
that's its beauty.
There's beauty in that.
And,
and you know,
this,
but when he did that to Matt Hughes and
when he hit Matt Hughes,
that flying knee,
there's beauty in martial arts there,
there is,
it's a well for,
for me,
it,
it always has been a creative outlet.
I can put together all these sequences
and all these different things and in a
way to solve a particular problem while
something,
somebody else is trying to do the same
thing against me.
And the margin for error is really
fucking thin.
You know,
if I,
if I zig when I should have zagged
kitchen,
a shin upside my head and um,
you know,
there's going to be bone exposed and um,
that's why this is a great thing as
well.
That's why I'm amazed.
So fucking cool.
It's so fucking cool to watch.
But the,
the preparation for one night,
like the idea that you're,
especially for a guy like you who came
off of a knee surgery,
you're out for a year and then you have
to hold out for more than a year for the
geography.
Right.
And how long was it?
Probably a 16 months.
So you have all this time building up to
this one moment.
How difficult is it to just to just be
in the moment when that happens and not
be overwhelmed by the fact that so much
of your future is riding on this.
You're not entirely set for life
financially yet.
You know,
there's all these different variables.
You have a wife,
you have a child,
you have a family of obligations,
you have all these things,
but yet here you are preparing for this
one completely.
Just,
it's like,
it just slips through your fingers this
moment.
This moment is just there that you
cannot,
you can't hold down and you're,
you're sharing this moment with another
trained killer and you're just locked
into a cage and you
future rides on your success.
Yeah.
Um,
I like to say that,
you know,
fight day,
know that that night could be the best
night of your life or the,
or the worst and you don't know fucking
which one.
And there's an incredible mix of
emotions.
And I feel,
I feel happy.
I feel sad.
I feel fucking nervous.
I feel,
um,
uh,
you know,
elated to be,
to be there and then fucking scared as
shit and I don't want to do this anymore
and I really just have to ride it out
and be in,
in trust,
in my training,
trust,
in the preparation that I've done up to
that point.
Um,
because me and my mind and my emotions
do all sorts of things,
but I just have to know that I've done
what I need to do in preparation for
this fight that I'm going to be all
right and that no matter what,
I know that I will never give anything
less than 100 percent than my best.
I will never give anything less than,
you know,
what you saw in that fight.
I may get knocked out,
but,
or,
you know,
it may,
may be an early night for me.
It may be a terrible night,
but that's out of my control.
I,
I gave everything that I could to each,
each round,
each training session,
uh,
each,
each minute of,
of,
of the training camps.
So that,
um,
when I,
when I step out there,
I've done everything in my control to
fucking win this fight and to compete to
the best of my ability.
Um,
there's also the things that are out of
your control.
You can't worry about that shit.
Injuries like injuries,
Tyron Woodley,
fight or kitchen,
that one that you don't see.
Yeah.
No.
And,
and you know,
shit happens,
but that's Kinda the,
that's the,
uh,
that's the thrill of it.
Does that make the highlights sweeter
knowing that those,
those,
you know,
the bad moments are out there that
they're possible?
Oh yeah,
definitely.
I,
it's like I said,
we're walking on a razor's razor's edge
on this thing.
I mean,
it could,
it could be a phenomenal night.
It could be terrible night,
man.
Fuck,
I don't know.
Nobody's died in MMA at this point,
but not in the UFC and the UFC,
but it shit could happen.
This is a tough thing.
What are your,
what's your feelings on weight cutting?
Like if you,
if you could be assured that
way.
Cutting.
We'd be out of the picture.
Like let's just throw all the weight
classes out and then let's just say
like,
what are you,
what do you walk around like one 85,
one 90,
something like that between [inaudible]
91 95.
If you could be assured that that is
just,
that's what your opponent's going away
and that's what you're going to wait.
You don't have to cut any weight,
would wouldn't you think that that would
be a better way to compete,
to just completely eliminate that from
the equation.
Just find out whatever is your natural
healthy weight and competed that instead
of this insane thing that everyone's
doing where they're dehydrating
themselves a massive percentage of your
body weight,
sometimes as much as 10 percent of your
which is getting sucked away in water to
the point where you could literally only
exist in that state for a short period
of time.
Couple of hours.
Yeah.
That's fucking bananas that that's a
part of cage fighting that one day.
To me,
I feel like the athletic commissions are
sleeping on a potential time bomb.
They're just ignoring that this is a
huge issue.
While they're concentrating on steroids
and epo and all these other things which
are real issues,
those things are unquestionably real
issues,
but just as big of an issue is massive
dehydration 24 hours before a cage
fight,
especially now that they've eliminated
the ivy rehydration methods and the fact
that we know now there's medical science
has proven that the brain does not
rehydrate as fast as the rest of the
tissue.
It takes longer.
It takes as much as 70 hours or 70 hours
too,
which is fucking crazy.
Or
the yeah.
To rehydrate your brain.
Um,
yeah.
I,
I think it'd be interesting to see
different proposals.
I know that one fc is doing something
well,
they've eliminated it there.
They,
yeah.
What are they gonna check your hydration
levels.
They're going to eliminate weight
cutting.
Yeah.
Well I know that they're doing the
hydration levels on like a collegiate
and high school wrestling,
um,
you know,
a level.
And I still,
I still know guys that are trying to
game that system.
Yeah.
We'll let him try to game that system.
But if you can eliminate that and tasked
hydration levels and like,
imagine like a guy like Johnny Hendricks
who never made it to the fight with
Tyron Woodley because the weight
cutting,
imagine them getting to a point where
they check them.
They go,
hey man,
you're fucking dehydrated.
You can't fight.
Yeah.
Like you,
you didn't make weight like you,
you're not where you're supposed to be.
Yeah.
I'm on the side of health for fighters
and these guys taking care of
themselves.
You know,
we're doing this for a very brief period
of time in our lives and you know,
the repercussions longterm from a lot
of.
The lot of the different stuff involve
including weight cutting.
Uh,
you know,
this is gonna have longterm
ramifications.
So for internal organs,
specifically kidneys,
right?
Yeah.
And I think it ages you man,
it,
especially if you're not doing it
correctly,
especially if you're not living a
healthy lifestyle year round,
all of a sudden,
boom,
I'm going to change the way that I eat
so drastically that my body's go freak
the fuck out.
Which you see a lot of these guys and
then they don't make it to the,
they don't make it to the way because
their system isn't used to eating like
this.
Most of you know,
eating a bunch of bullshit and now all
of a sudden eating Greens,
which is good for you,
but your body's still going to have
this,
this reaction to it.
Yeah.
And when you're not used to it.
Uh,
so yeah,
I would,
I would definitely like to see some
change.
Um,
you know,
if it benefits the health of fighters,
I'm all for it.
I don't think it could possibly not
benefit them.
I think that would be the biggest thing
that we could do.
Even more so than I think what the,
what Jeff Novitsky and the UFC is trying
to do with eliminating performance
enhancing drugs is awesome.
I love the fact that catching people.
I can't believe that they caught ul.
Romero.
Who would've thought that that guy was
taking steroids.
That's crazy.
Who would have thought that?
That's amazing.
Couple of those guys,
man.
I would've never believed it.
Him or Hector Lombard was another one
who saw that common.
That's nuts.
Vito Belfort,
are you kidding me?
Nuts.
Cyborg.
Really?
Wow.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I think that,
uh,
it's,
it's awesome because,
um,
I mean we're,
we're going to come to a point in time
in the real near future where it's
impossible.
Cheat.
I mean,
they're pretty close to it now.
They're pretty close to it now where
they are so good at catching people,
but they're,
they're also saving urine,
which I think is fascinating.
See Urine and blood for eight years,
so to test in case they don't have a
test that detects whatever it is you're
testing at this point where we can test
you down the down the way.
Exactly.
And you can come up,
which is cool.
They're super close to being able to
catch you doing anything now.
But what they're doing is they're coming
up with all these little designer things
and peptides and that's what you'll all
were got caught for some designer
peptide which artificially increases
your body's own production of
testosterone,
you know?
So they're doing all this sneaky weird
shit that used to be totally
undetectable,
you know,
five,
six years ago or what have you.
Yeah.
Well at that,
I think that's what they'd been doing
for a long time.
Correct.
Like they,
it's been like an arms race between the
dopers and antidote with.
That's what I understand with the Lance
Armstrong who was like a clear thing,
man.
They were like some super sophisticated
fucking programs to beat these tests.
Yeah.
And with Lance Armstrong,
one of the interesting things was
everybody was dirty.
I mean it's not like mma where you have,
there's a few guys that uh,
Novitsky,
I think he calls it the smell test or
the look test while you look at them and
you go,
who the fuck's going on over there?
Right.
You know.
But with Armstrong,
like none of those guys looked like your
marrow.
They were just little skinny guys on
bikes.
It's the nature of the sport.
And I think what they were probably what
they were taking is different than what
fucking,
you know,
big muscled up a prize.
Fighters are taking.
Well,
another important distinction about
these bands and about the banning of Ivy
Rehydration is now you can't blood dope
because they used to be able to blood
dope.
He used to be able to pretty,
pretty easy to just take your blood out
and then reinserted into your body.
You have more blood and you get the same
sort of benefits that you would get with
epo.
So you can't do that anymore because
they'll,
they'll be able to detect.
They can actually detect plastics in the
blood that come from the bags and from
the tubes.
It's fucking nuts.
It's wild.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
It's fucking crazy what they can do.
I've heard,
I've heard though,
like in,
you know,
we're talking about the arms race that
people can use a glass syringe class and
then um,
the van,
like a sterilized veins from animals as
their,
as their tubing.
That's,
that's whatever.
Oh my God.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Like sausage casing and shit.
Oh my God.
That's fucking.
Now they're going to check for big veins
down the rabbit hole with all that
stuff.
That's.
Well,
Novitsky was telling me that they've now
figured out a way to develop
testosterone from animals and it's a
semi theoretical at this point where
they don't,
they haven't caught anybody who's done
it yet,
and then maybe one of the reasons why
they're,
you know,
they're holding onto this blood for
eight years,
but he said they've figured out a way
because right now I don't understand the
process,
but right now the way they develop
artificial testosterone is through wild
yams.
They use Mexican yams.
I fucking don't understand it,
but somehow through yams they can
develop testosterone.
Those are manly,
manly Yam.
I've always said again what I am.
That's why pop pop,
I knew he was ahead of the time.
They make me feel manly.
So they've figured out a way through
these carbon isotope tests to detect
that the testosterone in your body was
nonindigenous,
that it was exogenous.
It's somehow or another from something
else,
but they won't be able to do this right
now,
at least with animal testosterone,
which is so fucking bizarre.
It will always be a race between the
cheaters and those who control those.
Uh,
with the French Tour de France secretly
symbolism,
a biking and a back in the early 20th
century there were doing it already.
And then today,
every Sunday there is some competition
somewhere like a local short distance
drafting and those,
you know,
Sunday athletes and they dope.
Yeah.
They're saying that like they check
executives that want to like show off
our taking epo and entering in
triathlons and winning them can put that
on their resume.
May Jack to the tits on EPO,
which is really fucking dangerous
apparently.
I don't understand he epo,
but the way it's been described to me
was that when you have so much extra
blood in your system,
there's a high risk of stroke and that
you have to mitigate the amount of EPO
and the amount of blood in your system
by constantly exercising.
Like you have to exercise.
You have to drink water and exercise.
Otherwise your blood gets too thick.
As we talk,
millions of people are doing crazy
things in their day to day life that are
going to mess up with their brain,
mess up with their whole physiology,
hormonal balance and stuff like that,
and they're not getting paid to do it.
They just do it out of whatever
ignorance or laziness or a.
So why wouldn't these professional
athletes of some of them,
especially in combat sports.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean there's one thing running.
Winning a bike race is one thing,
but not getting kicked in the head or
being able to kick the guy in the head
because you have that extra juice of
energy.
You know when you're tired and you're in
that fifth round,
but you come out because you're on epo
and you're fucking dominick Cruz,
step in and throw in high kicks and the
other dude is gasping for air.
That's,
that's where it becomes a huge issue.
Absolutely.
I mean we're talking,
you know,
potentially light.
Sure.
Well,
the way I describe MMA is it's high
level problem solving with dire physical
consequences and that's.
And we've seen it,
we've all seen guys get flatlined.
We've all seen people,
I mean,
you've done it to a bunch of guys inside
the octagon and it could have been you,
you know,
I mean,
it's a fucking nutty sport and in this
sport the doping has just a much higher
level of consequences or ramifications,
ramifications,
right word.
What's interesting to me though,
I'm absolutely anti-doping,
but I'm pro the science involved in it
because what we're experiencing right
now,
what I believe is that we are in a
period of time in human history where
our understanding of the scientific
understanding of the body and its
mechanisms and all of the things that
they can do to it is being sort of
deciphered and tweaked and poked by all
these various scientists.
Although I believe that should be
outside of competitive athletics.
We're going to get to a point in who
knows,
10,
20,
30 years where they're going to be able
to genetically reengineer human beings.
And this is all going to be out the
window.
I think we're kind of experiencing the
last years of natural competition,
gene doping stuff.
It's going to happen.
I mean,
they have this new thing that they've,
uh,
they,
they've figured out how to do or they,
because of this really interesting
science,
it's called Crispr is what they've
developed and there's,
I'll butcher it if I try to give you the
scientific definition of it,
but they can literally add genes and,
and manipulate genes and they're doing
so in small animals and you know,
small,
multicellular organisms and they're,
they're getting it to a point where they
really understand it and they're saying
that in China they're starting to do
this with human beings and they're
starting to fuck with it and test it and
you know,
you might see some Chinese Wolverine in
the next 20 years and you'll know that
that kid is the product of these Chinese
experiments.
You know,
I mean,
that's what they used to call corella
these to call Corella and the experiment
because if you've ever seen Carolyn's
family,
his mother and father like five foot
six,
they're like these tiny people.
And Carolyn was this fucking monster of
a wrestler.
You know,
if you,
do you know who we're talking about?
Alexander Karelin,
undefeated wrestler.
I mean,
he lost one time to rule on gardener,
but the only reason we lost is they
changed a rule.
They changed the rule that this is
Greco,
so crazy.
Whereas if you release your grip,
if someone gets you to release your
grip,
it's a point which is insane and that's
how gardener beat him.
Like he couldn't do anything to him,
but he got corella and towards the end
of his career,
you know what I mean?
He'd been wrestled forever,
but he would.
He was so scary that guys would try to
flatten out to keep from getting thrown
by him because he was so strong that he
would take these men 280 pound man and
he would just go under them while their
belly down,
flattened out on the mat,
just praying.
They don't get taken for a ride and he
would lift them up and throw them
through the air with all his weight and
their way.
Boom.
Coming down on them.
So he's essentially knocking them the
fuck out with the mat where everybody
else was wrestling.
He was wrestling as well,
but he was also hitting you with the
world,
you know,
it was crazy and no one knows how he got
so fucking big in history of sports.
There are always these,
these freak of nature,
these complete exceptional athlete in,
in a given,
in a given sport with what you say and
the manipulations that are going to be
able to do on,
on physiology may be using
nanotechnologies or indeed a genetic
modifications.
They might be able to replicate to clone
those,
those freaks of,
of science.
Oh,
they're going to work.
It doesn't happen in our lifetimes.
It will happen in our children's
lifetimes.
It's going to happen.
Science doesn't stop.
I mean it's.
If you go just go back 40,
50 years.
What they were able to do,
if you had a knee surgery,
you know,
like you're talking about your knee
graft,
they were fucked.
You're fucked.
You're crippled.
Bumpkiny.
Yeah.
That's just 50 years ago.
That's.
That's inside of a living person's
lifetime.
20,
25 years ago or less.
They weren't able to do this one that I
had successful.
Yes.
My friend Steve Graham was on the US ski
team and he's had some fucking insane
number of surgeries.
I,
I want to say he's around 18 knee
surgeries.
He said he has his knees,
kept like,
I'll,
I'll show you this real.
You fucking freaked out.
He has his knees resurfaced.
The tops of his knees are,
um,
it's all steel.
It's fucking bizarre,
man.
It's so,
it's so freaky to look at.
But he came around,
uh,
when they were doing all these
experimental surgeries,
they just,
they just couldn't.
They didn't know how to do it.
They just were taking all these risks.
And here it is right here.
I'm gonna show you this.
This is fucking freaky.
That's the surface of the inside of his
knee.
So he has no more cartilage and all the
meniscus has gone as well.
So if you see that white thing down
there,
that's artificial meniscus,
that's like a pad that they put in
place.
So they put this artificial paths in
Then they have the tops of the knee,
the top of the femur and that glides on
the Plastic Lusaka abstract painting.
It's fucking chaos.
Like dinner?
Yeah.
I told him to send me this after you get
your latest operation because he's had
so many operations.
He was so true down to the wire that
this is,
this is the latest sort of fix.
That's wild man.
It's fucking crazy.
And she's had multiple acl surgeries on
both legs,
MCL.
It's just the whole deal.
Meniscus scopes and this.
And that is nothing left.
They predicted that so many years ago
when I was a kid.
Uh,
Steve Austin,
whatever the name was,
man,
it was fascinating by them.
Yeah,
we're,
we're close to that.
I mean they're putting artificial hips
in people and having them being more,
no more durable than the natural hips.
Yep.
They're so using a exoskeletons.
Yes.
Especially in Japan.
They're really big on all these
robotics.
I got it.
Got An exoskeleton finding beautiful,
uh,
for people who really need it.
You had a very serious accident and
there's nothing can do,
but it's now your responsibility or you
come back from war and need that,
that kind of assistance.
In that case,
I believe it's beautiful.
Yes.
But my,
my concern is that these kinds of new
technology is going to be vulnerable to
millions of people who basically don't
give a crap about their body.
Their body has become completely alien
to themselves and the neglect it and let
it deteriorate.
You could think about it that way or you
could say,
you know what man?
It's just technology.
It's.
It can be used or abused.
I mean like cars.
I mean cars can be used to get places or
you could be a fat fuck and they just
will you over to your car.
You lose your way into the car and they
push you in and shut the door.
Then the car drives you around because
it's too fucking lazy.
The balance in there.
I think in our society,
we always go too far.
That exoskeleton for your body becomes
what the shoe is to your foot.
And I think that your,
your,
that,
your foot is going to atrophy.
Your body's going to atrophy because you
have.
Your foot has this artificial art.
But from birth,
like in wally,
you know,
I love that move you.
And the thing is that,
yeah,
it's freedom,
it's inevitable freedom.
You do whatever you want to completely
agree with that.
But ultimately it becomes the norm.
It becomes something that's not shocking
anymore in the wally world,
uh,
the movie in the end,
not being able to even stand,
let alone to walk.
Isn't that shocking?
It's,
it's the norm.
It's just something normal.
My grandma was able to walk a little,
a few steps.
Oh Wow.
She was extremely fit.
Know that we ultimately,
through generations we change the norm.
And so bear all won't be.
We won't be there.
Yeah.
But somewhat.
I like to know where we're going in a
good direction,
how the direction not to.
I don't know.
I don't know if it is,
it's definitely crazy.
I don't know if it is a bad direction,
but if we went back to a single celled
organism and I go look at these posters
with their multiple cells back when I
was a fucking kid,
you had to have one cell or happy.
So I don't think,
I don't think it's good or bad.
I think it's how,
how it's applied.
Yes.
You know,
and,
and is it beneficial,
is it right?
Is it detrimental and what,
what is the implication on a societal
level on like an overall thing?
We can look at tech technology,
you know,
the technology in general in,
in that respect.
Um,
I like to see that as a,
as a,
an,
as options,
as additional benefits to our current
society.
And culture means that let's imagine
topia like a society where every
individual would be,
would consider their own health and
movement ability,
eyes somewhat personal,
biological duty.
So there would really make sure that
they stay strong.
They stay healthy,
they can move,
they're there,
they're in shape,
they're sharp physically and mentally
and on top of that,
whenever needed,
they would punctually and wisely use
those technologies.
Then that will be an enhanced lifestyle
and society.
But when you have people,
it,
it's just there to support people who
have voluntarily disempowered and
themselves degenerate it themselves.
I,
I don't,
I don't like the direction that would
be.
Are we basing that on the current
paradigm though?
If we keep moving in the same direction,
it's entirely possible that you're not
going to need to be in shape or get in
shape.
You're just gonna be in shape.
You're going to have something that
they've invented,
whether it's some sort of a
biotechnology or what have you,
where you never get out of shape.
You're always physically fit.
Your body regenerates tissue.
If you lose an arm,
it grows back.
No,
it doesn't mean because here's the
problem.
You won't be the master of a technology.
Somebody else will the same way.
It's like if you ever stop growing their
food,
so when you're hungry,
you need that food to be delivered to
you to be produced for you.
If at some point the production of food
is in the hands of very little,
very few people,
there is no freedom anymore.
Okay,
so you said.
Yeah,
but it allows you to be always strong,
always fit,
always held the.
Yeah,
but the technology is in the hands of
the few people and when they want a
ticket back.
That sounds like some Illuminati type,
but it's.
It's,
it's,
it's that you don't have to go into a
conspiracy theory to think about,
do you,
are you in control?
Is it something that you can fix
yourself,
like a,
when you have a car or a boat or
something,
can you fix the technology yourself?
Does it belong to you,
do control it or not?
I think you're talking about things in
practical sense in a practical sense,
and I agree with you in a practical sort
of a pragmatic approach.
I'm extrapolating a hundred years from
now when it all it's nonsense because
I'm saying there's going to be come a
time in the future where there are no
natural athletes because there's no
natural.
People were probably just a few years
away from being symbiotically connected
to electronics.
We're pretty close now with phones.
Will you leave the house without your
phone?
You freak out.
[inaudible] met very few people live
without a car.
You know you have your navigation system
to get you around.
I don't really remember like three or
four phone numbers now.
When I was a kid,
I remembered everybody's number.
I can be able to call my friends.
I been able to call my house,
I barely know my own home number now
when I give someone my cell phone number
after think,
you know,
have to think about that number.
So you'll get both.
You do give up some of your control.
You didn't Google you get,
you get all sorts of good shit as well.
I think drew and the bad shit that comes
with it.
Um,
so you know what,
50 years ago they started or maybe
longer,
I don't know,
they started making a fucking process
foods and that was like the best thing
ever.
Oh my God,
we don't have to fuck it,
cook our food anymore,
throw it,
you know,
have it made for us in a factory and we
just throw it in the oven and it's done.
Boom.
This is the greatest thing ever.
You know,
fast forward 30,
40 years and now we're fat and unhealthy
and you know,
in our trans fats are national grop for,
for our healthcare is fucking,
you know,
or our healthcare cost exceeds our
fucking gross domestic product for the
fucking United States.
If it were just,
you know there's.
There's good parts of it.
Yeah,
they made.
They probably made food safer in a
sense.
Less people are dying from fucking
listeria outbreaks and that sort of
thing,
but on the flip side of that,
now we're really fucking sick and fat.
One hundred percent agree with you
Carlos,
because it's not like you could say,
wait,
that's.
We won't be very one with this will
happen.
There will be some adverse consequences
to the whole this,
to all of these,
but we won't see it.
It's already here.
It's already altering people's life
today as we speak,
that people are listening to us.
Maybe you know suffering from this and
that they don't even the why.
Well maybe you're surrounded by
thousands and thousands of chemicals in
older hygiene products that you know,
that you breathe that go through your
pores that go in your system,
that after your home,
a homeless sizes and stuff like that.
Maybe you're eating GMO.
Maybe it's everything is altered in your
day to day life and you see it as
something normal means you don't see it
basically,
and as an it doesn't bother you.
You're not conscious of it,
but it does bother you and how well you
live.
Well and and ultimately somebody is
profiting right then.
That's the thing is with,
with any of this stuff,
I mean it will become the norm if
somebody is profiting off.
Sure they can sell it to you.
If they can,
if they can convince you that this is
better,
whether it is or whether it's not,
but you know,
through whatever,
they're already selling water to us.
Maybe they'll sell air to us or are they
in some places provide canned air in
China.
Let me think.
They buy canned air with the little mask
on it.
You suck the candidate.
I've done that.
India and Japan.
Air Made My.
Made my veins.
Blue was wild.
Yeah.
Why?
Yeah,
because you had so much pure oxygen.
You could get it at like seven slash 11
over there next to the weird squid hot
dogs.
I did a an oxygen bar wants in Vegas.
They remember they used to have those
still around.
I think they do.
You put like a little pipe up your nose
and I'm supposed to be like,
what am I supposed to be getting out of
this?
Yeah.
It's like one of those oxygen things you
see old smokers will roll around with.
Yeah,
totally.
And the thing goes up your nose.
These little tubes go up your nose and
we're sitting there going,
okay,
what am I supposed to feel?
A sense of euphoria of extra energy,
and the cute chick that works there
comes up and rubs your back.
That's that weird thing on your scalp
and you kind of shit.
I thought good,
but it wouldn't come to come to a mind
to do something like that.
If you were in the mountain and the air
is pure surrounded by trees.
Why?
Why on earth would you try to put some
whatever oxygen in your in your brain,
you don't need it?
Well,
that's one of the things that I love
about forests and trees that you can
physically feel the difference in the
air because trees literally absorb
carbon dioxide and express oxygen.
They produce oxygen.
You breathe it in.
It feels.
My point is that you need these
enhancements when you're already living
within an environment that is a
tremendously deteriorate,
completely altered.
Then you're like,
oh my God,
I need their air and more natural food.
I need to try to make my even my,
my,
my house a bit more complex.
It stimulates my movement and things
like that.
That's because you were already out of a
universally,
I would say universally natural
environment comprising not just where
you are,
but what you eat,
how you breathe,
the light,
and even your home.
You own behaviors,
how much you sleep,
how you think.
All of that is behavior and environment
that will impact you positively or not
in term of how.
How will you look,
how well you perform,
how you feel.
It all matters.
All these variables matter.
What?
When?
What is your diet like when you're
training?
Do you have someone who monitors that
stuff?
Do you have a dietician that you work
with or anything?
So I worked with,
uh,
with my dolce for this last camp,
this last cut.
Um,
I met Mike when I was with my knee was,
was,
was hurting.
I was in recovery for that.
Um,
it was doing some seminars.
He was going and doing these talks at
some military bases on diet and
nutrition,
holistic living and um,
they brought me out,
you know,
as the special guest or whatever.
And I,
and I,
you know,
I spoke on a too,
but,
uh,
our,
our philosophies on,
on food and nutrition clicked.
I mean they were,
there pretty much aligned.
We have a little bit different
approaches.
Um,
I started learning about nutrition from
a strict,
excuse me,
the strength and conditioning coach when
I was about 19 years old up to that
point.
It was,
it was,
you know,
whatever.
I fucking eaten off the dollar value
meal at Wendy's.
Really?
Yeah.
During the time you're like fighting the
WEC or.
No,
this was before then.
This was,
I was fighting in like little little
casinos out in the middle of the desert
in New Mexico and like making $200 for a
fight if you're lucky at a 400 person
venue.
Um,
and yeah,
so it was like,
oh,
if I only eat half of this four piece
nuggets,
I'm definitely gonna make wait tomorrow.
Yeah.
And you know,
yeah.
I vividly remember those days.
Anyway,
I got with this guy and he just kind of
taught me the basics,
you know,
basically taught me,
taught me about macronutrients and he
mainly a train bodybuilders but gave me
some basics.
And then since since that point I've,
you know,
uh,
through my own practice,
through my own practical applications of
running through these training camps,
running through,
um,
the,
these weight cuts and,
and absorbing information,
going out there and looking at
information myself,
um,
have kind of figured it out on pretty
much on my own.
And uh,
I cook,
I fuckin love to cook.
That's my,
my hobby.
And so that helps out because,
you know,
I'm,
I'm cooking at for fun,
like kind of as a,
as a Cathartic thing after I'm training,
but it,
it works well because I'm cooking the
nutrient dense food that I need to
perform and to train and to make weight
and to be a high level athlete.
I saw that you and Irwin,
we're working on bowhunting exercises.
Do you do,
do bowhunting?
Uh,
yes.
I,
I started,
started bowhunting three years ago.
I have yet to fucking kill anything.
I am not,
I'm very much a novice.
But uh,
you know,
I'm learning.
And uh,
is anybody teaching you A.
Yeah,
I've gone with some guys,
um,
some,
some older guys that are my dad's age.
My Dad's not an outdoorsman at all.
Um,
you know,
he likes to fish but you know,
he doesn't go farther than about 20 feet
away from his car to fish.
So this,
all this stuff,
or one,
if you could back that up a bit,
please,
Jamie,
to that bow hunting thing that you just
show,
showed what is exactly is involved in
these bowhunting exercises that you've
got them doing.
So that was in between the two camps
that we did together and uh,
uh,
Carlos already knew he was going to
fight Robbie lawler.
She left,
but it was a somewhere or just just
fucking around Baltimore and yeah.
Yeah,
it was somewhere a late September if I
remember.
Well.
And um,
New Mexico is the best spot to hunt elk
next to Colorado,
New Mexico and Colorado.
These spots in this country,
you.
Mexico is the best place to live.
Really?
Think.
Well,
no.
Listen,
listen,
let's keep it a secret.
But what,
why do you say that?
Um,
Diego Sanchez lives there.
Yes.
The beauty,
the landscapes.
But,
but again,
it's the people will prefer another
place,
but,
but there's a certain energy,
you know,
some places resonate with you more than
others.
Me,
ah,
I moved to Santa Fe,
New Mexico,
never,
never left.
And then find a Jessica,
the,
you know,
my soul mate and up and everything is
beautiful there.
And will your cheeses,
it's a perfect place to live in Santa
Fe.
A lot of hippies.
You got a scarf on even though you're
indoors.
I'm European,
I can afford it.
Whatever,
you know.
I'm French.
So when you said to that guy,
fuck you.
Oh,
so what you love?
You Love New Mexico,
New Mexico.
I'm a,
I'm a new Mexican now.
I can feel it,
you know,
like they say a born here on my life,
but definitely don't sound like,
you know,
I have a profound love for these land
there where I live.
It's surrounded by 19 Pueblos on native
Indian energy,
which I really relate to.
And um,
oh.
So you can go and see these ancient
sites where they used to live.
You can,
you can,
they still live there?
And some of them right?
Like in the mountains,
the mountains,
the.
Yeah.
Well the,
yeah.
There's lots of emotions kind of old
school,
like,
like a stone age apartment buildings.
And they didn't,
they have cable and now they have cable.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
they got,
yeah,
they got satellites hanging off the side
of him now and yeah.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Dad,
if you ever come out to New Mexico,
I'll take you by Akamai.
I'm going wild.
I've been thinking about going into
Mexico and doing a show there for
awhile.
I want,
I want to do something.
Probably Albuquerque is a good place to
go,
right?
Albuquerque or Santa Fe.
Where should I go?
A Santa Fe is an hour away,
so come in Albuquerque and then boom,
boom.
There's a lot of stuff right around.
Come on.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh,
there's,
there's the,
the Apache caged area,
Apache,
Ms Dot petree reservations.
It's still there.
It's really a lot of grit,
that energy,
a lot of cool stuff.
But
it's a secret.
Let's not talk about it too late.
So with regards to the,
the honestly,
the stuff that we were doing wasn't a
whole lot different than a,
what we're working on for the training
camps,
you know,
we're working on foot,
ankle,
knee,
hip stability in complex environments,
in walking on,
walking on logs are navigating different
terrain while staying aware of my
surroundings.
You know,
if I'm fucking sitting there looking at
my feet and stumbling over myself and,
and worrying so much about being quiet
and where I'm standing fucking I miss
miss a Goddamn,
you know,
some something right there.
And I'm feeling with your feet saying
that,
that Irwin has that helped me out quite
a bit as kind of a coaching cue is put
your mind in your feet so that I'm
looking here and I'm aware of what's
going on around me,
but I can feel where I'm going.
Boom.
I,
I hunted like a,
like minimal boots so I can,
you know,
I could feel if I'm about to crack that,
that stick and make that,
you know,
what kind of boosts who are,
like,
they're,
they're called,
the ones I use are called mini mill.
Um,
and they are high a,
m I n I am I l l I think is what it is.
And they're,
they're dope man.
So I think initially,
uh,
the,
the vibrams fivefingers came into vogue
in,
in the military.
They,
they loved it,
right?
And everybody was all about the,
uh,
the minimal footwear.
But if you go to minimal,
too fast,
you're going to hurt your feet because
our feet,
our bones,
our tendons,
our muscles are atrophied from being in
basically casts for,
for,
you know,
our,
our entire life and all of a sudden I'm
going to go run a couple miles like I
did in these supportive shoes.
And you're going to get stress
fractures,
you're going to get all kinds of
injuries.
Um,
so I think the military,
a couple of the branches,
band,
the band,
the five finger shoes or the five.
Yeah.
And that's what they're called.
There's people getting hurt because your
foot injuries,
what are lots.
Lots of people,
people's body's physiology are just not
ready to strike.
And you have to work your way up to
fight.
And this.
Yeah.
This guy runs,
runs barefoot throughout,
through the mountains.
You run barefoot.
Yeah.
Don't wear any shoes at all.
No.
Well sometimes,
but it depends on what I do,
but I do try and also to be barefoot
because it makes me extremely sharp
mentally.
You have to be extremely focused,
just not injure yourself to be
extremely,
uh,
adaptable.
So he doesn't just drained,
people think,
oh,
okay,
so it's gonna make your,
uh,
the sole of your foot tougher.
What about that?
What's special about that?
But that's not the point.
That's not much many more benefits
beyond just making your feet tougher.
It's so fascinating that when in the
invention of the running shoe,
which what they thought was an
advancement,
oh,
we're going put cushioning.
It'll
save people's bodies,
the wear and tear,
and it actually wound up fucking people
up and getting more injured.
The food is a masterpiece.
There's nothing to change about about
it.
Human food is a masterpiece and a,
yeah,
you try to come up with some science
caring science shoes,
footwear.
It's bullshit,
but also just need minimal minimal
protection to avoid abrasion and end
punctures and things like that.
But otherwise you need to lead the work,
uh,
the work as naturally as possible.
And if you don't then you will make your
feet weaker,
right?
It will,
it will,
it will shrink it,
it will numb it.
But then on the flip side of that coin,
I can't,
my feet aren't strong enough to just go
and run as I would normally in
completely minimal shoes.
I have to kick back,
I have to kick back the intensity and
the distance.
So if I really want to get a really
hard,
hard run in and,
and,
and get,
get fatigued,
I need,
I throw on some,
some regular old running shoes.
Shorter distances.
I'm,
I'm like specifically training my feet
and you know,
and,
uh,
conditioning my tissues and everything
to be able to do that.
And that's,
you know,
that's kind of a,
a distinction.
And,
and,
and moving to hurt myself,
moving,
moving barefoot in wall and environments
is not,
um,
it's not men mandatory to people say one
a mandatory,
forgive my French.
I just thought when I have to do the
math in my head as to what you said,
I feel like I have to clarify for people
as well.
That's good.
Thanks.
Um,
yeah,
you don't have,
it's not mandatory.
Mandatory.
Mandatory correcting.
Sorry,
my English is very good.
English was better than my French.
Um,
you,
you start,
you start a resetting your body in a,
in a,
in a more natural way through these
natural movement patterns,
and you can do that in indoors
environment,
even wearing some minimal footwear and
then you remove a footwear and then you
start to expose the body through these
natural movement on more challenging,
more complex environments.
Ultimately if you want to,
you can become,
you can go through these more say bad
ass trainings where it's like the real
deal.
You're in the wild.
They're maybe cactus and sharp stones
and all kinds of things.
And,
and,
and still you can do that,
but that doesn't mean that you have to
do that right away.
Or did you ever have to do that?
Um,
uh,
the bowhunting practice was,
yeah,
these balancing movements.
The point was not just the movement
itself is when you move in complex
environments,
there are also situations.
If,
for instance,
you're hunting,
you'll goal is to catch the game.
So you need to be aware of what's going
on.
You need to avoid being detected and you
need to look and scan your surroundings
and be as light as possible,
a silent as possible.
If you're already in trouble with your
movement.
If you're already struggling,
we have a movement.
How much of your brain activity and
awareness is going to be dedicated to
the situation itself,
which is the hunting part because the,
the,
the movement part in the,
in the environment part is already.
It's not there.
Your struggling.
Uh,
it's not just a matter of,
oh,
I have some cardio,
so I'm good.
No,
well maybe you have hard time just
kneeling,
getting up and getting down,
let alone in a supple silence move way
that is not the deck detectable.
So what?
Well,
learning kind of things were trending,
bow hunting in particular,
sort of experienced this,
uh,
most recently,
this fitness mo movement where a lot of
guys are getting in extremely good shape
to be able to run the mountains so that
they can hike long distances and not be
fatigued and so that they can take shots
like in,
have some mobility where you can be on
your knees and for long periods of time
you might have to be held at full draw
while animals looking at you after
having run up a hill.
You're fatigued.
Yeah.
And it's the difference between being
successful and not being successful.
I mean in today's day you could still go
to the supermarket,
but ultimately what it means is whether
or not you can eat or not eat.
So you have to be in physical shape to
be able to do that kind of hunting.
And a lot of it is at high altitudes.
So you're trudging through the mountains
of low oxygen.
The body and mind I have
to deal with so many diverse variable
changing in.
That's,
that's again,
that's adaptability.
It's about adaptability a gut.
The chance,
uh,
to,
to train the seals in Coronado,
and these guys are well,
number one,
they are gentlemen,
they are real good,
good people,
but they are extremely fit from the
stance,
uh,
the standpoint of how much they can run,
how much they can end dirt,
but I would challenge them with very
simple movements,
a chai,
some of the movements with Trent
together with Carlos,
uh,
the,
when you were in that split squat
position,
and you pivot,
reverse your orientation from forward to
backward and while maybe holding a stick
that represents a rifle or bow or via
camera if you're shooting photos.
So if you're struggling with that
movement,
you have imbalances.
How much,
again of your situational awareness can
be dedicated to the situation at hand,
at stake.
That's a good point.
You surviving the movement will excuse
me in the close to the mic.
Oh,
alright.
And then for a split second or maybe for
a little longer,
a,
you're in trouble.
So,
uh,
in,
in the cage situation,
it's very similar because you need to
always keep an eye on your it.
So you need that situational awareness.
Well.
So not having to think exclusively at
how you move.
So the more comfortable in movement,
the more fluid,
the more second nature it becomes,
then the more attention your brain can
dedicate to the situation and to the
adaptability,
the range,
the timing.
All of these subtle little adaptations
in your brain is in charge of brain
commands,
not the body.
So the money deans to be able to,
uh,
to,
to move a highly reliable way ultimately
that it is the movement itself or the
situation,
situational awareness.
It all boils down to the brain.
What I was getting at before with the
bowhunting is a.
and with regards to your diet diet,
do you eat wild game or do you get like
what I do?
Yeah.
Um,
mainly I eat a grass fed free range
meats.
I get as much wild game as I can.
Like I said,
I didn't kill anything in the last two
years,
but the people that I,
I did go with,
did they,
they,
they harvest harvest elk.
Um,
so,
you know,
we all share that meet.
So yeah,
I eat as,
as,
as much wild game as possible because I
feel like that's,
I mean,
that's about as pure as you can get.
It really is healthy too.
When you eat it.
It does have a different effect on your
body.
You can feel it if you're,
if you're health conscious and if you're
aware of what you're taking in on a
regular basis are sort of aware of how
your body reacts.
You'll see it,
you'll feel different when you eat wild
game.
It's just more nutrient dense.
Yeah.
And,
and there's,
you know,
there's other aspects to it,
man.
When you,
when you see the animal die or you kill
the animal,
there's just a sense of gratitude.
I feel like for this thing,
giving its life to nourish your body as
opposed to buying something in a nice
little neat package with fucking Saran
wrap over it.
You don't even,
you don't really think that a life was,
you know,
was separated,
um,
to give you two to nourish your body.
But when you,
when you go out and you see it or it's,
you know,
it's in front of you.
You realize that you're a little bit
more connected to what you're putting in
your body and I think that disconnect is
a part of the um,
uh,
the problem with our,
with our food,
you know,
I guess sickness or food culture that
we,
you know,
there were,
there were experiencing these days.
The gratitude is certainly an aspect of
it and also the connection,
just to an understanding,
a real understanding of what happened,
how you got there,
what,
what this meal is and it just,
it has,
it feels better.
It feels better to eat it.
Yeah.
It's a mix of things you,
you actually feel as opposed to just not
even thinking about.
Not even just now,
Mike Dolce you were saying,
uh,
works with you for,
or worked with you for this last camp.
What was the difference?
Like what,
what different things did you eat and
what,
what approach did you take?
Did you do any work to examine
your nutrient levels?
I did not.
I didn't do any blood work.
Um,
the difference was we didn't change what
I was eating.
We changed the structure and the timing
of when I was eating,
um,
I,
I was kind of a man.
I didn't,
I didn't have much of a structure.
I was like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm eating the right things.
I'm,
I'm good.
Um,
he,
he's like,
okay,
well,
no,
this is,
this is how we're going to do it.
We're gonna,
you know,
gonna do,
you're gonna sit down and you're going
to eat till your full.
Every three hours you're going to have
two feedings.
You're not going to kind of snack and
graze here and there,
which is what I was doing.
Um,
and uh,
do to increase my energy levels.
I'm immensely.
How,
so in what way?
I feel awesome.
So I,
I don't know why,
I don't know the physiology behind it,
but,
um,
I think it's a hormonal.
I think I.
So after I would eat these big meals,
boom,
oh,
get,
I would get tired.
I get like a,
um,
kind of insulin dove,
you know,
be tired for a little while,
but the next time I went to train,
like I just felt like I had had more
fuel.
Um,
you know,
more energy,
more sustenance for these training
sessions.
Um,
and uh,
my weight cut was,
I,
I've never had a weight cut as,
as easy as that we were eating,
you know,
f full large meals right up until the
night or even the night night before
weigh ins.
Why I was,
I was,
I came down so quickly and I,
I kind of have a weird deal,
man.
My,
I feel like my body,
I've,
I've cut weight so many times.
I have,
you know,
40 plus professional fights,
between kickboxing and MMA and I think
my body just kind of knows.
It just drops.
Even Mike's like,
dude,
I've never worked with an athlete that
just boom,
boom.
It was just,
it's just on a schedule,
it just might,
my weight drops.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
but I felt,
I felt amazing.
I felt good in the fight.
I think I look good in the fight.
I performed well.
Um,
the,
the cut was,
the cut was awesome.
So you're eating big meals,
I mean,
fairly bi relative,
relatively big meals.
How many calories have encountered out?
So I would say I would have probably a,
a,
an eight ounce portion of,
uh,
of Salmon.
I'm probably a cup of white rice and
then a good amount of vegetables.
Um,
you know,
we're talking about several times a day.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting because most people
think of weight cuts being that,
you know,
you severely restrict the amount of
calories you have.
Your body starts to go into ketosis or
what have you,
starts absorbing fat instead of,
uh,
instead of carbohydrates,
you dehydrate yourself.
Then after that.
And that's how you get to that state.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean that's one way to do it and I've
definitely done that way before.
I've done it.
A bunch of shitty.
What's the worst way you've ever done
it?
Just the chicken nuggets way,
but hesitant right around that same
time.
Not,
not eating.
I remember.
So my first kickboxing fight ever,
I fought a guy named Andy Sour.
I don't know if you're familiar with it.
That was your first kick.
My first fight.
First kickboxing fight ever.
Fucking as that you're managing.
How long has andy been fighting then?
He already his record at the time,
I remember too,
and for some 93 in one.
Oh my God,
that's so insane.
It through when I was first kickboxing
fat,
all my God.
So I was 12 and o as an mma is an MMA
fighter.
Oh my God.
I was 19 years old.
Um,
I had maybe one or two amateur boxing
fights and I had been training him or
I'd been trying to kickboxing for a long
time,
but anyway,
I go up to 91,
1993 and one.
Oh Man.
What fucking governing body sanctioned
that?
Uh,
it was in Japan was,
I was,
I was the guy who lived in Japan.
Exactly.
I was the guy that they were bringing in
for the slaughter.
Oh my God.
Uh,
I,
I show up out there and I'm only,
I think I remember I was only like eight
pounds out and we didn't know what the
fuck we were doing with,
with regards to the weight cut at the
time I was 19.
And so I'm like,
Oh shit.
And I just stop eating.
I just didn't eat for about four days.
Oh No.
Oh no,
that's so meanwhile,
eight pounds ain't shit.
I'll do that.
Yeah.
The day before a crowd.
Oh,
we're good.
Yep,
exactly.
Still still eats one of the sauna.
Yeah.
And so I started myself for about four
days and we check in your weight.
Oystar and yourself?
Yeah,
I think it was.
I don't remember.
It's a long time ago,
but it was same day weigh ins to.
Oh Christ.
I waited in the morning and then fall
about maybe eight or nine hours later.
Oh my God.
And uh,
I went five rounds with him.
I went,
I,
I got,
I got my ass kicked,
I got my ass kicked.
But I,
I learned a lot and I grew from the
experience out.
Imagine Shit.
Any sours.
A legend.
Yeah.
That is so crazy.
That was your first kickbox tk owed me
with 17 seconds left to go.
He shot,
he had chopped my legs down.
So to the point where I couldn't even
stand,
I was falling through the ropes,
so it was all fucked.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
It was cool shot.
I went back in,
I came back to Albuquerque,
I went down,
down to the gym and these guys had been
kind of throwing me around up to that
point.
I specific specifically remember Diego
Sanchez,
I mean at the time he's like king of the
case champions,
like the man in New Mexico managed
Jackson's and you know,
he always gave me a,
you know,
really,
really tough fight at are tough
sparring,
sparring matches at that point.
And after I went through that
experience,
it was just kinda like that.
You can't do shit me.
Wow.
Nothing just changed you.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
That's amazing.
Well,
what a fucking crazy matchup that is.
That's criminal.
You should find out whoever matched you
up and go beat their ass.
I know,
I know.
Who did it.
I'm glad I shake their hand.
That shaped me.
Well,
for you,
for a guy like you,
you can handle it,
but God damn that could have.
And I think they knew that this column
syndrome.
Stockholm Syndrome,
right?
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Would be becoming friends through
captors.
That's insane,
man.
What a crazy fucking match up.
I've never seen.
I've never seen it.
I've never seen a video of it.
I think it's out there.
Wow.
I think even Andy Sour hit me up on one
of the social media.
It's like asking if I had ever seen it.
I'm like,
no.
Bad.
Up to this point have not.
It was an undershoot boxing rules,
so shoot boxing,
I don't know if you're familiar,
was billed as no holds barred standup,
so it throws and take downs with
kickboxing.
Oh,
okay.
No.
Elbows like Draka.
Remember when they used to do that?
They were doing that in the United
States for a while.
Was a kickbox and would take downs.
I don't remember that,
but it.
That's,
that's what this was supposed to be.
Maury Smith did that for a little bit
and standing submissions was yeah,
you were supposed to be able to do
standing submissions and I actually
caught him in a few chokes standing and
I think the rules were if the guy hits
his knees,
he's.
They break it and they stop it.
Why?
I don't know.
It was weird.
It was.
It was cool,
man.
It was.
It was a good experience.
I was 19 years old.
I got to go to Japan.
Yeah.
Well fight for,
I don't know,
probably 500 bucks.
I don't even remember Japan's crazy.
Did you see rising sea rise in Japanese?
Um,
the,
the new year's show with fader.
I did not ask ultimate freak show.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Cool.
Yeah,
it was almost like,
kind of like early days of pride where
it was like Kinda chaotic.
Like Gabby Garcia was there.
Two hundred 20 pounds.
I saw that fight.
Yeah.
Choose to the fucking ear lobes.
She,
she got dropped right off the bat,
but she came back and she cracked the
chick with a back fist fucking back
faced coming back.
Man Arlovski with Travis Brown.
He landed a back fist.
Oh,
this one?
Yeah,
a regular back.
It's not a spinning back fist.
A regular back fist just to pimp,
hand backhand.
Pan Pan.
But um,
it was two days of fights.
Wow.
Yeah.
Sakuraba.
I might've been more than two days.
Sakharova fought Aoki,
which was just criminal.
They shouldn't let Sakharov a fight
anymore.
It's just awful.
The wound.
It's not how old he is,
it's the miles,
you know.
He's probably younger than Anderson.
You know,
if I had a gas,
I would.
I would say he's younger than Anderson,
but the beatings that guy's taken.
Did you see the Melvin manhoef fight
when Melvin was soccer kick him and he
was down.
It was so hard to watch those vandelay
knockouts that he suffered.
Those are brutal.
Ruthless in that guy has been through
the ringer.
You know,
he's,
he's so corrupt.
What a legend.
Now that guy is what?
A legend.
Absolutely.
I remember the first time I saw pride,
I saw him fighting hoists gracie.
Wow.
That was that 90 minute fire.
Was that 90 minute one and had he had
hoists in that,
that like dead to rights,
newborn hoists would not tap what ended
up happening?
I was at a decision.
Yeah.
Well it was a draw because they want the
90 minutes and nothing happened.
Yeah,
I think it was a draw.
I think that that's how they say no,
no,
no.
Hoists broke his ankle.
That's right.
Didn't he break his ankle and he
couldn't continue?
Fuck.
Why do I not remember that,
Jamie?
I'll pull it up.
He'll find out.
All right,
cool.
There was two fights.
They had another one in k one,
and that was in America.
I was there live for that one,
and Noyce was juiced up.
Pig was yoked up.
Then he tested positive and they find
him a fuck load of money.
Don't know if favorite ever paid it,
but he patched,
but now he's back.
He's fighting,
which is crazy.
He's fighting Ken shamrock.
I saw that on a on tour.
Yeah,
it's the main event in February.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It's so strange.
I remember their fight was the first
fight ever,
so it was first UFC fight.
I had ever seen Sakharova and hoists.
No,
no,
no.
Ten in Canada.
Canada hoists and voice was choking the
choke.
Choked him with his ski.
Yeah.
It was wild,
man.
That was the early days.
Men.
The first fight I ever saw was Orlando
veit versus rem co pardot when Graham
called pardue took him down and elbowed
the fuck out of him and from side
control or you had them like that and I
remember watching that going,
oh Geez,
a Christ.
What kind of fucking crazy sport is
this?
The pardot Guy Kinda hits him a few
times.
Then it kind of implies that he's
knocked out and you kind of just let
them go at the time.
Would just let them mainly.
Yeah.
Oh,
big John Big John was one of the reps
back then.
Crazy.
You remember when?
Um,
uh,
what the fuck is his name?
Fought that Ninja dude.
Pat Pat Smith.
Pat Smith's fought some dude who was
like doing,
like they had his,
his pre-fight video and it's preflight
videos doing like Ninja techniques and
like fucking all this crazy shit that
doesn't really work.
And then he got in there with Pat Smith
who was a pretty seasoned kickboxer
yeah.
And it was dropping.
Just wicked elbows on him from the mount
and knocked him out and then woke him up
and then knocked him out again before
the ref stopped.
Yeah,
well he got up and was just a bath of
blood.
His whole head was essentially opened
up,
but that was the early days.
Man.
The early days were really fascinating
because you,
you were around martial arts before the
USC,
so you had seen like,
you know,
you'd seen karate and you'd seen all
these different judo and all this
different stuff and nobody really knew
what the best stuff was.
I always knew that wrestlers could take
it down.
I always knew that was gonna be a
problem because I wrestled in high
school and I had a good buddy of mine,
my friend Steven Arduino when I was
doing taekwondo and he was wrestling.
One of the reasons why I got into
wrestling because I didn't think that he
could take me down out in the grass.
He was like,
I can take you down anytime I want.
I'm like,
Bull Shit.
He took me down over and over again.
I was like,
this is crazy.
It was so humiliating,
like he was just,
he just took me down every time you want
it to,
and I was like,
this is Matt.
I got to start wrestling.
So I started wrestling.
That's one of the reasons why I started.
Another one dude got me in a headlock
and fucking threw me down in the locker
room.
Could have beat me up,
but didn't know it was like God dammit
Braille.
So I had to learn wrestling,
but I always knew that wrestlers could
take you down if they wanted to,
but I always felt like a guy who knew a
little bit of wrestling,
it was a good kickboxer would probably
be able to keep the fight standing,
but then when he started choking people,
I was like,
oh no,
it's a whole different thing.
This is a completely different thing.
That guy beat that guy from his back
with a fuck winds on their back.
Like it was just a whole new element.
You know?
It's interesting because you've been
around from the WEC days,
which were when you were the wec champ,
like it was.
It was so small in comparison to what it
is now for you to go from that to that
last fight against Robbie in Vegas,
which was just this massive fucking
media event.
You're fighting for the world title.
You get there,
the place is sold out.
It's craziness.
The roar of the crowd,
you know,
time and like what a fucking odyssey
you've been through and your career
because you,
you were there sort of when it was kind
of just starting to take off.
Yeah.
I really got in on the ground level.
Even before Wec,
I told you we were fighting.
It's like 200,
300 person venues in the middle of the
desert and it's been crazy,
man.
It's been a.
it's been an incredible ride and it has
been the coolest fucking thing ever I
want to do as a young kid.
None of this existed and,
but I was into the early nineties
martial arts movies and Ninja turtles
and I wanted to be,
wanted to be a Ninja.
I,
that's what I wanted to do.
I remember my mom,
that was the second movie that I had
ever seen was the first Ninja turtles
movie and I came out of there,
what should fucking kicks and spinning
shit and,
and,
uh,
every,
you know,
from then on I was training to be
something and just so happened I lived
in a time that this came to be and lived
in a city where there was this camp that
was,
you know,
by,
kind of inexplicably good,
um,
for
a small podunk place like albuquerque,
but not just an exclude explicably good
for the,
what it was,
but also for the time.
And it evolved,
whereas a lot of those camps that were
big back then,
like the lion's den,
they're gone.
You know,
the Pat Miletich is Jim.
It's gone like these,
these gyms that were really big at the
time,
they didn't evolve or they didn't carry
on or for whatever reason,
they stopped doing it.
You know,
your,
your gym is not just evolved but evolved
to be one of the premier gyms in the
world.
It's really kind of incredible.
Yeah.
And there's been a lot of change,
you know,
somebody,
a law,
like a lot of the original guys have
branched off and are kind of doing their
own thing.
But um,
yeah,
the,
the genesis of MMA in Albuquerque is
kind of an interesting story.
Um,
and,
and I don't,
I wasn't there,
I was like,
told this,
I was,
you know,
this is kind of,
firsthand hearsay from the people who,
who did develop this thing is that
basically these guys from these
different disciplines got together and
they had watched the UFC and wanted to,
oh,
I have a wrestling background.
This guy has a chemical background.
This guy is like a,
you know,
a Akka karate kinda background,
whatever.
They all got together and they started
formulating the shit in this one guy was
a flight attendant and he was flying all
over the country.
And every,
everywhere he'd stop,
he would,
he would go to these different schools
because there wasn't the internet at the
time.
You couldn't jump on youtube and look at
techniques.
So he would go,
the guy's name's Chris Luttrell and he
cornered me for my fight against GSP,
uh,
and what is one of the founding members
of Jackson's.
He was going to these different Jiu
Jitsu judo pankration schools and see
what they were doing that he was
bringing the information back and they
were.
And then they were,
you know,
Kinda getting into the laboratory and
see what was working.
At the same time.
Some of these guys were bouncers and
police officers and,
and,
and literally using this stuff on the
street in some,
you know,
some had roadhouse type fucking
situations.
That's awesome.
Read.
My original trainer was like a Patrick
swayze from roadhouse type kinda guide.
Tom Vaughn,
I don't know if you know Tom von.
Yeah,
he means yes.
And his NHP now in albuquerque as well.
And he was,
him and Greg were,
I mean that,
that he's one of the founding members as
well.
It's kind of crazy that there's two big
gyms like that in a place as small as
albuquerque that have UFC fighters while
they split their.
Yeah,
they're from the same place.
They they branched off at one point,
but they split up.
It's crazy that these both guys have
developed really high level talent
because they all came from the same,
the same original.
Think.
That's
a fascinating story about the flight
attendant.
I'm sorry,
what's the name again?
Chris Luttrell.
Cristal trial [inaudible] him traveling
and doing that.
That's similar to what Halas Gracie did.
Whole holes did holes.
Gracie traveled to America and learned a
lot of wrestling shit and learn catch
wrestling stuff.
That's why the Americana is named the
Americana.
It's uh,
it's uh,
you know,
it really came from American catch
wrestling and they started incorporating
into Brazilian jujitsu along with some
wrestling techniques and some sambo.
And he learned a bunch of Shit.
And he was the guy that really was
Hickson's mentor.
He was the guy that was the head of the
family before he died.
He was the man and he died in a hang
gliding accident and Rio.
Yeah.
And he was the,
he was the guy,
like he was the head of the,
all the others,
you know,
he was the one alpha of all the,
uh,
the grapplers.
And he,
he was dedicated to learning and
incorporating different techniques,
I think,
like in any other context of those were
the most adaptable and most open to
change and evolution or those who
survive looked for a remember Eddie
Bravo,
uh,
showing uh,
he,
he's approach to and Resi Hixon Gracie.
And why is it so hard?
Why is it hard on me?
And he was,
despite his,
he's amazing knowledge and background
and achievements.
He was open enough to listen carefully,
respectfully with Vienna,
with humility.
But you even asked questions like
Hickson was asking questions about
different aspects of the positions and
coming from the,
the,
the Bjj world.
That's,
that's unusual actually will hixon is a
very unusual guy.
Hickson was a Yogi,
like he was the first guy to incorporate
yoga and he is a legit Yogi,
like have you ever seen the videos of
him doing those exercises in Santa
Monica where he's balancing on one leg
and he puts his leg up and a full split
is incredible control of his body and
enhance the,
the people,
uh,
legitimately,
legitimately saying,
hey,
rickson was the first to implement
movement spreading.
He was,
yeah,
he was,
but here's the thing to me,
uh,
I want to pay tribute to all coaches
that they are Moitai,
tighe,
striking coaches,
Judah coaches,
even strength and conditioning coaches.
They all,
all movement trainers and movements,
fishers,
they all are well more or less
specialized,
but they are.
It's a movement.
It is.
And you know,
there's an interesting aspect that's
going on right now in 10th planet
Jujitsu with break dancers.
There's a bunch of these guys like
Richard Martinez who was a break dancer,
like amazing breakdancer and his brother
Geo.
These guys,
they can do crazy shit with their body.
They standing on one hand and spinning
around and because of that you have
another term hip hop a lot about how you
control your hips,
which is the fundamental of Jujitsu.
It's,
I don't think that's where like because
it rhymed,
it came from,
it came from like,
I'm hip hop dance,
different sugarhill bent hip hop,
hip hop.
What'd you guys had?
Incredible movement.
They didn't show it much.
They had to to.
They're the rhymes over shadowed their
fucking stability,
their courses.
There's the dance and then there's the
music and then there is in Breck Denson.
You're going to use these guys.
You're going to use your hips a like
crazy.
I'll.
His movements are achieved because you
have great hip control.
Look at Ninja Jitsu.
He must have this drip country.
Look at this control.
Play that from the beginning.
Jamie,
watch with this guy can do this is just
one of the breakdown.
Look at he's standing on his fucking
head justice said,
but trying roles.
Yeah.
All sorts of stuff.
Absolutely.
Well these guys,
um,
when Eddie first started training them,
enrolling with them,
he was amazed at how freakishly strong
they were and you know,
you look at them,
they look like regular people,
but it's the physical control of their
body is just spectacular because of,
you know,
it's essentially similar to gymnastics
and a lot of ways like,
look at this fucking ego level.
Oh my God.
And walking on his hands.
This is nuts,
man.
That is fucking nuts.
What's the name of this video,
Jamie?
So people are listening to like watch
this 10th planet break dance crew freak
show.
Yeah,
they all call themselves freak show.
He's got a,
he owns 10th planet San Diego trying to
submit himself.
Uh,
yeah,
you can submit himself.
There's a couple of kids that can put
themselves in triangles,
like legitimately put themselves in
trials.
So we get this fucking shit.
I'm sassing but admire at the same time.
This Kale.
It's,
there's no doubt.
Oh,
there's no doubt of the physical control
of the body is just spectacular.
And this is the first time I've seen
this,
but I mean I can see that the
application to combat sport.
Yeah.
Immediately I've rolled with a couple of
these guys.
They're fucking freaks.
I can't hold onto them.
Yeah.
They move all over the place and they
can catch you in shit from all sorts of
weird angles like look at that and he's
on one hand that he puts his legs and
full logus standing on one hand jumping
up and down.
Tenth Planet Jiu Jitsu is a very,
uh,
explorative innovative school of,
of Jujitsu and um,
in,
in the,
in the game of MMA,
of those gyms who also are open and
collaborative,
arguing to kid themselves.
You know,
at the upper echelon,
um,
and those who don't evolve will,
will disappear because it isn't till the
methods,
the,
the end result is the same.
It's the fight it's fighting,
but the methods to get there and to be
proficient at it,
it's,
it boils down to the methods that you
use.
And uh,
with uh,
with Carlos there was a,
there was no resistance when I
approached him and start to try and he
talk to his coaches about it and they,
they may not understand right away
exactly what it was about.
Well,
what was going to bring to his game,
but they were at least open to it and
eventually this saw a what together
we've been able to,
to improve and achieve.
And if,
if,
if it didn't have that attitude,
then Carlos would have not benefited you
contact a Jackson and Gregg and
winkeljohn before you worked with her
one or did you try it out first and go,
Hey,
uh,
I think I'm onto something.
Um,
I think,
I don't know,
I don't,
I don't remember how that worked,
but it was really interesting in Erwin
touched on it earlier,
was that they saw the same thing.
They both watch it.
So after my widening the stance,
yeah.
And,
and the,
the ability to move forward and back we
me and uh,
and uh,
Greg Jackson sat and he wanted to watch
a couple of my fights and we want to see
what we're doing well and what we needed
improvement on a few things and I
started work with Erwin completely
independently and you know,
we're walking on logs and this and that.
And he's like,
well,
this is kind of a plan that I have for
you and this is what I see.
And it was exactly the same thing that
Greg Jackson,
who is considered to be one of the most
brilliant minds in mma saw.
I'm Erwin,
is a movement specialist in Irwin had a
plan and a strategy on how to improve
that.
Um,
what was Jackson's idea of dealing with
it?
What did he think?
He knew what needed to be done.
I don't think he necessarily knew how to
get there.
So he knew that you needed to be able to
move in and out better?
Yes,
but he didn't have any strategy.
I wouldn't say that he didn't have any
strategy.
It was kind of,
okay,
you know,
we'll work on that.
Let's figure out how.
Let's,
let's work on that.
But I'd be just drill it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Drilling a Irwin and I,
we,
we videotaped my,
we videotaped us moving across the same,
the same distance and the students fast
man,
he's like a fucking deer.
He moves really,
really,
really quickly.
He can run,
he can,
he does.
He's got that look into that fund myself
and the color of the wood with me being
a so called deer and these guy with his
boat because he shoots like super sharp.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so videos you're going back and forth
and so we're,
you know,
we're looking at and we're,
we're,
we're looking at this stuff in slow mo
frame by frame where his body position
is compared to where mine is and what's
the difference.
He's moving faster because boom,
he's more upright.
He doesn't have so much weight on his
front foot that he asked to load and
take another half second before he just,
he springs backwards.
Right?
And so we're like,
boom,
that's it.
This is what,
this is what we need to improve on,
this is what we need to do.
Now we're going drill it and,
and there's a variety of different
things to kind of in a,
you know,
it's still that,
that a stance in the posture as a,
on a neuromuscular level.
Are you having other fighters
approaching now?
Not yet,
but really I saw that video.
I would imagine the video.
Have you guys trained together?
There is still some,
probably some skepticism can have West
this Moltmann coaching and lucky and it
looks like it doesn't have.
It doesn't look like Jesus doesn't have
a man bun and Isu have foreign accent.
It's a ripoff.
Right?
So,
um,
I think that they don't know exactly
what it is about the end.
They probably believe that it's either
rent a random or.
But if you listen to what Carla says,
um,
it is actually,
it was highly specific because a can't
be three months,
we would train once a week,
maybe sometimes twice a week,
but that's still a limit on amount of
time to make those changes happen.
So I had to choose my battle and then I,
I,
I told Carlos,
listen,
this is what I believe we need to work
on and just focus on.
And we did that for the first camp and
then the second camp for a loader was
completely different,
uh,
and,
and highly specific to,
uh,
improving,
kicking.
What were you gonna say you're going to
say we actually,
we do have some guys that are,
they've been doing this kind of
independently.
They,
one of the,
one of the guys,
young guy,
and they're fighting on like amateur and
regional levels,
but you have a feeling we're gonna
you're going to know their names here in
the next couple of years.
They're up and coming.
Guys,
they're young,
like 21,
22,
23 year old,
you know,
kind of making their way.
Um,
one of them has been watching Irwin's
videos since he was 15 years old.
He met her when he was all star struck.
Oh my God,
this is the core.
How did you even,
you know,
and,
uh,
they are incorporating movement quite a
bit,
so it's not,
you know,
it's not that they haven't sought him
out there,
they're kind of very interested in this
and doing their own stuff and,
and,
and finding this stuff on online and
watching the door tech portal stuff,
watching Irwin's stuff and um,
and,
and definitely incorporating a lot of
this stuff.
And one of the kids is a gymnast,
a gymnast before and,
and so now he can do all kinds of crazy
shit and they're looking for a niche.
Definitely they'll looking for an edge.
Even Carlos was looking for,
well George St Pierre was doing a lot of
gymnastics.
Cummings does a lot of that as well.
It's the same thing now we're like,
we,
you know,
we see with conor mcgregor.
So it's like this big thing.
All of this,
uh,
GSP was,
he was,
he was doing gymnastics for the same
exact reasons to be able to move his
body better through,
through space and ultimately become a
better able to better beat the shit out
of people.
That's the goal,
right?
You know,
it's,
it's fun and it's cool.
It's a cool way to train and,
you know,
after the fact,
I think it's,
is a cool fitness,
mobile modality that's very different.
I,
I absolutely love it.
I've been an athlete all my life and I
can,
I plan on being an athlete to the
fucking day I die.
How much longer do you think you're
going to be fighting?
Um,
have you considered that?
Oh yeah,
because I've heard you talking about
that after the Robbie lawler fight.
Um,
I dunno,
it's,
I'm,
I'm probably,
you know,
31.
I'll be 32 in a few months.
You're still in your prime?
I am,
but you know,
this has been,
it's been a long road.
You know,
I started training profession.
There's fighting professionally at 18
have had 40,
you know,
over 40 fights and you feel it.
You get dinged up,
I get dinged up and I,
I still feel great,
I think.
I think my concern is the longterm
neurological stuff that is kind of
coming to light with,
you know,
with all this studies on concussions and
you've seen me fight.
I don't,
I don't go in there and not take damage
and I fucking take damage,
you know,
I take take punishment,
I take,
I'll take two to give one and that's
just Kinda my style.
And well you didn't fight like that and
Nick Diaz fight.
That was like one of the few fights we
didn't fight like that.
Yeah.
You know,
I felt I had seen a lot of guys go in
against Nick Diaz and gas themselves out
trying to knock that guy out.
And it's like he can't,
you can't knock him out.
He took a full on a left hook from,
from Paul Daley,
flopped around a little bit,
pop back up.
Paul Daley Blues was trying to finish
him and then and then got knocked the
fuck out himself.
And I've seen a lot of guys,
you know,
hurt him,
but he's so God damn toughy,
so hard to put away.
And so yeah,
it was more of a,
um,
of a calculated approach,
you know,
as I got flowing later in the fight,
I started opening up a little bit.
But,
um,
I think that's what a lot of new ideas
or strategies he,
he wants for what he wants to get in
your head and he wants you to fight
emotionally.
He wants you to sit there and have a
face punch,
punch competition with,
you know,
oh,
we're going to stand here like it's the
fucking school yard.
Was he talking about shit to you?
He was,
but I just,
I knew I knew what he's gonna do.
I mean,
I grew,
I grew up with tools like that,
you know,
my whole life I was.
So I was kind of used to that and I knew
that I was going to have to be
emotionally.
I'm a prepared.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Emotionally,
uh,
kind of shut down and just fight a
strategic fucking game plan against the
guy.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
it was interesting to watch that fight
because he was extremely frustrated by
that,
you know,
and he couldn't get you to change,
whereas he's been able to fuck with guys
heads like the frank shamrock fight.
Like you could see frank shamrock going,
I can't fucking believe this is
happening to me.
Like when nick was talking shit to him,
like what bitch,
what?
And then popping them with a jab.
You could see like for some people that
shit-talking becomes overwhelming with
nick.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny is a,
both me and cowboy fought the Diaz
brothers within a few weeks of each
other.
Right.
A cowboy lost to nate and I fought nick
just a few weeks later.
And in,
in preparation for both of our camps we
would,
we were switching roles and both
fighting southpaws and both fighting one
round I would fight southpaws talk a
bunch of shit and try and try,
try and try to get,
you know,
try to emulate his style.
And then the next round he would do the
same.
This is yell out Stockton motherfucker.
I,
I did my best in pressure,
reminds me of a Buddhist,
a hmong drill where they're all in their
meditation posture and uh,
they,
they partner up and the other guys like
trying to instigate them and no crap to
them to have them get out of their
meditation as the drill the.
Well,
there's definitely something to that.
I mean,
if you're not used to people that talk
shit when someone talks shit to you,
it can be emotionally devastating what's
happening here.
But if you used to be like,
fuck you,
I've heard this shit,
you know,
it becomes normal.
You know?
I mean,
I tried to explain that to fighters when
they deal with online criticism as well.
Like I've talked to guys who would go on
like the underground and see like some
shit that people are talking about them
and just be fucking devastated and get
so upset.
And I was like,
look man,
you got to treat it like snake venom.
You get a little bit of that shit in
your system and you're going to be okay.
You get a little bit more and eventually
you build up an immunity to it and then
you go,
oh,
I get it.
You're just a bunch of little console
who've never accomplished shit.
So you talking shit about fighters
calling them pussies and like,
because some fighters you have a loss
and you're like,
good,
I'm glad he got knocked out.
I fucking hate watching that guy fight.
He's a pussy like damn stuff.
Oh my God.
It's initially it as like,
it was like,
whoa.
After that,
you know,
I'd never experienced that until really
until after the deal is there had been
some.
But after the Diaz fight,
I mean,
you know that big time.
So yeah,
I call it the shifts and what I call it,
the unique snowflakes.
A snowflake syndrome.
Lucky or told,
since you're a kid,
you're a unique snowflake,
but the problem is that day they can't
stand the heat.
Does that make sense?
Who are you talking about them?
I love who is the unique snowflake,
the person talking shit or the fighter,
whoever is like being told all the time,
hey,
it's okay to be different or it's okay
to be this.
And that problem is that sometimes you
do need to,
uh,
hear stuff about
yourself that is challenging and to take
it to not crumble,
crumble really know.
You need to hear it.
I mean,
I would,
I would appreciate it man.
It's hard because I like both ways.
I kind of love like Nate Diaz punching
Michael Johnson the face and then
pointing at them.
Ah,
I just fucked you up.
Like,
it's funny,
you know,
when Anderson fought nick and nick laid
down on his back and pretended to sleep,
sleeping for a second.
I was fucking crying,
laughing.
I love it when conor mcgregor talks mad
shit to Joseph all for months until he
just rent space in his head to the point
where although just he literally can't
fight his fight.
He has to run at conor because he's just
so overwhelmed with emotion.
And then connor sleep some.
You know what I mean?
I like both,
but I prefer in a.
In a perfect world,
I prefer martial artists.
I prefer guys that go out there,
treat each other with respect,
shake each other's hands and then just
go out and just let their skill,
but it's an effective tactic to these
fighters.
It's part of their weapons.
Fuck.
It's not something outside their their
game.
It's completely embedded in their whole
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's also a slider is defined themselves
by respect,
by how much someone respects them and
how.
How much like like to a fighter when
someone's not scared with them,
it becomes a very devastating thing.
Like I remember when Anderson fought
Chris Weidman when right Weidman and
they understand what the winds and
Anderson staring at him looking at him
and Weidman goes,
I'm not scared of you,
dude.
I'm not scared of you.
And you could see Anderson was like,
shit,
this guy really isn't fucking scared of
me.
Like you could see there was a tangible
moment where this guy wasn't pretending.
He wasn't scared.
He just literally wasn't scared.
Then I could feel it.
That similar situation at the weigh ins
with Ronda Rousey and Holly Holm.
Yes.
Same thing and I felt like that was a
precursor to what ended up happening.
Well,
the big part was when Holly didn't
flinch exactly when Rhonda was yelling
at you,
fake bitch,
you know,
preacher's daughter,
all this stuff and stuff,
and she bought all this stuff on
instagram about her and holly just
standing there and then when I
interviewed holly afterward she goes,
well,
it's just trying to get a sip of water.
And you realized like,
Whoa,
this girl is so fucking composed,
like so composed.
And it also,
she had been to so many dances.
She fought for so many boxing titles and
kickboxing and MMA.
She'd been in so many dances that the
bright lights were in an uncomfortable
thing to her.
She had.
She's like,
okay,
we're here again now.
Whereas for a lot of people it's like,
Whoa,
this is the big show.
Holy Shit.
I can't believe I'm here.
Yup.
Being overwhelmed by the moment is
almost something that you can't prepare
for it.
It seems to me that for a lot of people,
some people just naturally can deal with
moments and some people they have to
experience it a couple times to get
loose.
They get got to get comfortable with it
and then they have to like some people
like cowboys.
A perfect example.
He fights his best when he fights a lot.
He's got to fight all the time.
He fights three,
four times a year in then you're going
to get the best cowboy you can get,
but you make them take a year off or
take a long time off and it's just.
He's much better when he's active.
He's gotta stay loose and loosened up
and fired up and to fight with Tim
tiffany means is going to be fucking
crazy.
Yeah.
They announced that.
I was like,
whoa.
Why did cowboy decided to take that
fight?
Because he doesn't like cutting weight.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I haven't.
I haven't talked to cowboy,
but I mean I said,
hey,
what's up?
You know,
we didn't,
but we didn't really talk about the
fight at all.
Well,
he's so crazy.
You could probably offer him brock
lesnar.
He left.
Come on,
bring it on.
Oh,
for sure.
Exactly.
Do it.
That's it.
That's why he's because he's cowboy.
Yeah.
He's just nuts,
man.
Yeah.
He's a fun dude,
man.
Yeah,
absolutely fun to watch.
Fight and fuck.
He's either.
He's either on or he's off.
Yeah,
unfortunately.
Unfortunately.
Well,
I don't even necessarily know if he
wasn't that he was not on.
I said Dos Anjos.
He's a fucking demon.
He's just jumps all over you.
He did that to him.
Did that to pettis?
Yeah.
Nobody's done that to pedis man.
Dude,
but he's just so fucking fat and again,
he's a guy who trains with nickerson.
Nickerson has gotten doing all these
plyometrics and jumps and sprints and
foot strengthening stuff.
You ever seen that stuff with her?
They're lying on their back and their
feet are pushing up these bars and
they're kicking up these bars and
catching them with their feet and
exploding with their feet.
I saw,
I saw the video for the cowboy fights.
It's all based on Marv Marinovich is
training stretch strategies as the same
sort of shit that he used with Bj Penn.
Really,
it's really interesting that I remember
watching that and bj was standing on the
tennis balls and all that sort of,
you know,
very similar,
very similar.
And it's,
you know,
it's all veRy similar,
kind of look at different ways to
different branches,
but it's all kind of,
you know,
all this,
the same goal.
So what's next for you now?
Do you hang back for what?
You had a brutal,
crazy five round war for the title where
it was as close as you're ever going to
fucking get.
I mean,
a lot of people saw it your way.
A lot of people saw a robbie's way was
just that close split decision.
Um,
what do you do now?
I,
I'd like another shot at robbie,
you know,
I,
I felt like I won the fight.
Um,
and like you said,
it's razor,
razor close decision could have gone
either way.
Mma,
judgIng a subjective,
the scoring system so fucking crazy to
it is nuts that we're still using that
10 point must system.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
doesn't apply very well to animate it
in.
That's proven over and over again.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I'd,
I'd like another shot at,
uh,
at robby,
I feel like I should have the belt right
now,
but it seems like tyron woodley's next,
right?
I mean at least he was sort of promised
that and based on the hendricks we're
hendrix didn't make weight and um,
it seems like that's what's probably
being set up,
but you never know what the doc mean.
Misha tate was supposed to fight ronda
if she Beat jessica.
I think that's who it was.
And then they decided no.
so it's,
it's interesting because the ufc kinda
decided to call the shots.
Has anybody talked to you about whether
or not they would do that again?
Uh,
I think it's,
it's definitely a possibility.
Uh,
you know,
I think the first fight they made that
fight because that was the fight that
people wanted to see among any of the
contenders that,
that,
that was the,
that was the one that got everybody
excited that that was the one and a
rematch of that fight.
Oh yeah,
come on now.
Well,
I think as far as public interest,
that would be the biggest fight out
there.
Yeah.
But I feel like I just hate when someone
gets promised something,
you know,
and I would feel the same way if it was
you like tyron woodley get promised that
title fight.
If he beat hendrix,
hendrix fucks up.
It doesn't make weight and the fight
fights off and then woodley sorta left
out to dry.
I feel for him,
you know,
and I do too.
And,
and shit,
you know,
have,
I have a last woodley and that that's
definitely on my radar to,
to,
to avenge that loss,
a loss like that and injury loss.
Fuck with you as much as a loss by
decision or you know,
I mean that's a kind of a crazy loss
because you need blew out.
Yeah,
I think even more so just because the
fact that I,
I didn't get to do as much as I wanted
it to do,
you know,
I didn't,
I didn't get to leave everything out
there.
This,
this last one.
That's a bummer.
I didn't take the belt home that night.
Didn't go my way,
but I pushed it.
I was able to fucking empty the tank.
He definitely emptied the tank.
Yeah.
And in the woodley fight I didn't.
Um,
I,
you know,
my body gave out my knee blew out.
So,
um,
yeah,
from that perspective,
I,
I definitely see where you're coming
from.
YeAh,
I mean,
yeah,
he,
he was promised a fight,
but I'm not in charge of tyron.
I'm not in charge of picking the fight.
I'm in charge of,
you know,
carlos condit and trying to get myself
in the best fight.
That being said,
you know,
honestly,
that's about the only fight that
interests me at this point.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
I wouldn't be mad if they decided to
make a rematch.
I feel bad for tyron,
but a fuck.
I'd love to see that again.
Yeah,
I'd love to do that again.
That's how much time would you need off
after a fight like that?
Um,
I think it'd be,
it'd be ready to go and,
you know,
late spring,
early summer,
ufc 200.
Sounds good to me.
I don't know.
That would be,
that'd be ufc 200.
That's home.
My goodness.
You know,
I,
I wanted that fight to be legendary and
I think that it lived up to that.
Oh,
it was legend and it was one of the
greatest fights I've ever seen.
yeah.
so I've probably called 1500 fights or
something like that.
Something crazy like that.
That was easily in
the top 10.
Just everybody wants to see a sequel,
a concept like an unfinished.
Tyron woodley.
He's right now listening to golf and I,
I understand where he's coming from,
but yeah,
I get it.
I get it to hey,
maybe they can go fucking give him a
little.
Sorry.
Alyssa tyron,
kick back,
relax,
have a good time.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
I dunno,
I still,
I still love this shit.
I mean,
I still,
I still love the process 20,
can't even fucking fight week.
I enjoy and you know,
that's awesome.
One of my favorite things in life is to
get in there and pick and mix it up with
a guy like robbie so.
Well it was one of my favorite things to
watch because it was just an amazing
fire.
It was,
like I said,
after the fight,
it was an honor.
It was an honor to be there and to call
it because I know that when
this was all over and we're old and
we're sitting around at a bar at a
picnic someday or were picnicking.
If I want to,
talking about,
we're talking about the past,
we're going to talk about that fight.
You know,
the way people talk about leonard and
duran or with the way people talk about
any great crazy fight that they were.
They were there for,
you know,
and in winter lose.
Ultimately that's,
that's what I want to be said.
That's the legacy that I want to leave.
Well,
I think it was martial arts in its best
form and a lot of ways it was a heart
determination,
willpower technique,
uh,
the discipline to go through camp to get
yourself in the kind of shape that you
need to be in,
to compete for five rounds like that,
which is just an insane amount of
physical conditioning immune.
You guys fucking emptied and your
workload was extremely high in that
fight especially kicks.
I remember that was one of the things
that we commented on,
like how many kicks you had thrown.
I mean,
it was a really a really fucking crazy,
crazy fight.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was fun,
man.
I had fun.
I don't know,
maybe maybe I'm a little bit twisted,
but,
uh,
that was uh,
I was definitely say you're a little bit
of,
you know,
that was the kicks were a big part of
the strategy to,
uh,
I think that a lot of people wonder why
is it that a lower was not as aggressive
as usual.
I believe there is a reason because it's
not like he was less hungry or listened
in shape.
It's because the strategy worked,
have a higher volume and a courtesy and
uh,
with,
with those cakes to,
to lower his,
his aggressiveness and worked with kicks
her always so dangerous too because it
just takes one slip up,
you know,
it's there,
there is so much harder than punches and
you're taking them on your arms and they
fuck your arms up the point where you
can't throw punches anymore.
So you gotta be careful what you absorb,
right?
It's part,
it's the volume is statistically the
volume is getting to create damage to
two different diverse part the body.
So when,
uh,
you know,
I've,
I've heard the debate about the fight
metrics,
how I threw a lot,
I didn't necessarily land a lot.
Um,
and I feel like the kick and the kicks
and the,
the volume of,
of punches that I was,
that I was throwing out was the
equivalent of a say,
putting down cover fire.
If you were in a firefight.
Yeah,
you're not necessarily a,
you know,
pop and people's nuggets,
but you are,
you know,
that it's part of an overall strategy
to,
to come out with victory.
You're,
you're your throwing him off,
you're making him keep his hands up,
you're keeping that distance.
You are making the enemy.
Keep their head down in this analogy and
you weren't also loading up either.
You were touching them with a lot of
theSe things and keep him on his toes
and you know,
that was something that dwayne was
calling tj dillashaw to do in his fight
with dominick cruz.
He was to just go out and touch them,
just keep touching them and then the
shots will come,
but he got so emotional and tied up and
trying to knock dominic out.
You could see him standing flatfooted
swinging more single shots,
single kicks,
single punches this.
Yeah.
This guy that had looked just incredibly
dynamic with his footwork and his.
He kind of looked like dominick cruz
against other guys and look really well.
Dominick cruz goes out there and makes
him look like a very orthodox,
a fighter.
He's not,
he's not moving like that.
And at times,
yeah,
at times initially they came out and
they were both moving like that.
I'm like,
oh,
well this is.
This is crazy.
These guys are going to open up a worm
hole.
It's going to be wild.
Well,
I think that's what a lot of us
expected,
but um,
it's interesting that would,
what uriah said about tj,
that he had a feeling that tj was going
to get emotional because tj is a super
competitive guy and he'd get really
geared up and you know,
that's a,
that was an interesting fight.
Really interesting fight to watch.
It's crazy that dominick cruz able to
come back having essentially only fought
once in four years.
Yeah.
And,
and when the title.
I like that.
Yeah.
He's a different kind of animal.
He's a smart motherfucker to.
You talked to that guy.
Oh yeah.
I've known him since wec.
I listened to his analysis of fights,
like when he talks about like what
mistakes guys make and things guys are
doing right and correctly and what they
need to do and you know,
you realize like he's operating on a
very,
very high level,
very high level.
Absolutely.
And that's probably part of why he was
able to come back and compete at the
level that he did because he,
you know,
he was sitting there analyzing this,
they,
they talk about,
you can sit there and do repetitions of
a kick or a technique,
you know,
100 times,
but it,
it's almost the same,
uh,
thing neurologically to visualize
yourself doing that.
They say that that visual visual
training is a similar,
very similar and almost as effective as
actually doing it.
Yeah.
So I wonder if,
I mean,
I wonder if there's kind of a,
of a correlation there.
I would imagine there is.
Well,
he's interesting in a way also because
he says that there's no such thing as
octagon rust like I asked him about and
he's like,
it's not real octagon,
it's mental weakness if he believes that
it's true,
but when you watch the fight,
it certainly looked true.
I mean,
he didn't look rusty at all.
It's just fucking kind of nuts.
Um,
I think that's the thing.
It's a belief thing.
He's not going to let that.
Not for one.
One second.
Hinder him,
agree with carlos,
because in the absence of of actual
movement training,
due to his injury,
it's very likely that it was tilled
visualizing everyday.
He's movements in therefore using his
brain to keep practicing the movements,
even though a body could not,
the body could not follow out that,
you know,
during that time you examine dominic's
footwork to examine guys that are
fighting.
Do you watch like different guys
movements and it's close to perfection
in easy using a particular technique.
Yes,
but also most importantly,
it's all about he's alertness and
responsiveness and timing that again,
it's,
uh,
it's not how much your body can,
can do it,
how much your mind is.
He's able to operate your body to
achieve that.
Yeah.
So you need a brain that is extremely
sharp.
Um,
well I was super impressed with him,
but one of the things that I thought of
when I watched that fight is goddamn how
good his mighty mouse,
you gotta take a leak.
So what's going on?
Yeah,
let's just wrap this fucker up.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
we Did almost three hours,
but listen,
thank you very much was absolutely.
Thank you everyone.
Really appreciate it.
Joe.
So,
uh,
your twitter handle is a,
there's move nat,
nat mov,
mov nat.
And then there's also yours,
which is a just irwin core move now.com.
And you could find it on my twitter page
because I tweeted it today and carlos
carlos condit and move not.com.
Move nat.
Nat,
nat.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
All right folks,
we'll be back tomorrow with the guys
from cowspiracy.
Holy shit,
here we go.